Talking about your fucking tie. I could
talk about that quite a bit. Tie Bar
one. Boom. Gavin McInnes
you are lives sir,
from Williamsburg, Brooklyn, which I
understand you invented. Yes I did.
Congratulations.
Thank you very much.
When you see all the hipsters
walking around just like you,
do you feel proud sort of um, you
like the bay, the Daddy? Yeah,
I'm the godfather of
hipsterdom. I don't feel, I,
I've always been sort of anti follower.
Like there's ways you can get
followers where you, you know,
don't piss anyone off.
And I probably could have a big following
with these super far right dudes.
The Kuk service give
guys cuckservative yeah,
they call you a cock if you race mix
and stuff. Oh, you're that Jamie.
I see you this time.
It's a first,
but I ostracize them is for being erased
mixer and then I could probably get
gamer followers, but I think it's gay to
play video games. Oh, like the Gamer gate.
Yeah. People. So I lost those
gay, homosexual male gay in the,
in the grade school sentence.
Layman. Why? Why is it, uh,
why is it lame to play video games?
Video Games are fun.
You're pretending you're
Batman and 40 years old,
you can be 80 years old and still pretend
you're Batman. Yeah, it's still fun.
Remember when we were kids were
probably the same age. How old are you?
I'm 45 48 so you'd see those guys playing
star wars when with 10 year olds when
they were like 13 and you felt
bad for those guys. That's true.
And now those guys,
the average video game players,
31 but why is it okay to play chess and
it's not okay to play like a real online
strategy game?
I've been thinking about that a lot
actually this week and a really? Yeah,
and I think it's because when you
play a silly game like poker or chess,
there's some social interacting going on.
Like you'll go,
you fucker,
right?
Like you're in the room and you're
talking to the guy and you develop a
relationship and then you know,
later on you guys are at a bar
or something and it's like,
you fuck me just like
you did. Like, you know,
two months ago with that
checkmate move or something.
So it's improving your relationship
with the people around you. Hmm.
That's interesting. I never really
considered that. But video games,
you're shooting monsters.
It's into the void.
It's a Ephemera you're
blowing away time like dust.
Well they found that video games actually
do improve cognitive function in some
sort of a strange way and even can improve
but improve your, your uh, vision. Sure.
Gray. It's Kinda crazy
cause you know your vision,
you're darting around the screening,
especially like first person shooters.
You know,
you're looking for things that are trying
to kill you or you're trying to keep
the cab drivers in London
have that overdeveloped part
of their brain that does
directions. Really. Yeah. It's,
they can physically see that part of
the brain is sort of in gorged the
directions part of the brain.
Whoa.
So if they do like an Fmr eye on them or
something like that. Yeah. It's like, uh,
someone who has cat scans could probably
identify a London cab driver. Whoa.
That's crazy. So that's good.
You're working out a muscle.
But I witnessed a cab driver screaming
and Uber driver last night, you know,
cause he's fucking Uber drivers.
They look like it's just,
it looks like a normal Camry
or something like that. Right.
And there's a cab driver and the cab
driver is pulling up these people that are
waiting for something.
And I don't know what the deal was with
the people had called an Uber or call a
cab and a new Uber. You know, sometimes
people do that. People are assholes,
you know, they'll call both and
see, let's see who shows up first.
And the Uber Guy was in front of
the cab drivers honking his horn,
screaming at them and the Uber driver
that you can always tell the Uber driver
because they always have an iPhone and
one of those little iPhone holders so
they could type in the address and just
go. It's always like sitting right there.
Yup. And um, you know, I'm like,
am I about to see some shit go down
cause I was right next to it. I was like,
this guy's going to get out and kicked
this guy's ass or something's going to
happen. But nothing better
than seeing a live fight.
I've seen a lot of them couples to
male and female couples having fight.
If you go to New Orleans during Mardi gras
and she's wasted and you're just like,
I'm going to pull up a
chair and grab some popcorn,
but I love riffing with people and I
fucking hate cab drivers because they're
from another country and
they don't know how to riff.
Like the guy that brought me here,
I'm like,
what's going on with the traffic
on the other one? He goes, what?
These these years going that way?
Yes, dude, what do you think? I mean,
we're not in traffic. This traffic
right there and he's like, oh,
he's maybe the had of going
someplace maybe. Yeah, I know.
I'm trying to get into like, are they
shopping? So you want the small talk?
I want the small town.
I don't want the small talk.
So when I get the small talk I'm like,
I have to pull my earphones out. What?
What do we,
oh yeah,
I guess they're going to
give it up because you've
been abused by immigrants for
so long. I want to riff with
barmaids. I want to riff with drivers.
I want to riff with the woman I'm
ordering my coffee from and I just,
I just see these immigrants
doing these jobs and I go,
these are teens jobs were in the teens.
Oh,
like driving cars or teens jobs. Yes.
Really? Well, I actually, you know,
I drove a limos for a bit when I was
in my twenties, my early twenties. Um,
but um, what's mad at
Jamie as Flemmi? Let me,
let me extract, uh, elaborate a
little bit here in 2015 with Jay,
a unemployed teens everywhere
and unemployed college students.
They should be driving camps.
Now. I've traditionally,
I liked the idea of Archie bunker with
the stubby cigar and the tweed hat saying
that he saw a prostitute die right on
this corner as we drive. That's ideal.
Right.
But I'm saying as far as fixing the system
now I want teens doing immigrant jobs.
See, I don't want teens driving.
Definitely. Yeah. No Day. No,
I didn't like the way I
drove and I was a teenager.
I don't want anybody like me
driving me and I don't mind, uh,
immigrants as long as I can ask them
like where they're from and like you're
going to learn some
weird shit about people.
That's what I asked the guy here I go,
it's English.
He's just massacring the English language.
I'm watching someone just
murder it is his place and I go,
no, you mean is the place
we're going to a company. Yes,
he's placed company and
there's no interest in learning
the language that I go,
how long you've been here for.
And he goes six year,
I'm like six year fives in Armenia for
six years. I would be Armenian poet. Yeah,
but he could just go to Glendale and
fit. Right, exactly. I almost asked that.
I almost said, I almost said, why do
you only hang out with Armenians? Right.
Like had assimilates anymore.
I like Armenians cause there
the last unabashedly masculine
like ethnicity in this country.
Like skins or machismo sort. Yeah,
that's true too. But they've,
they've integrated more and
to the American culture,
especially in southern California,
Armenians,
they walk around with gold chains
and wife beaters on and yeah,
those string vest. I have a friend,
he's Armenian, his name is Armen,
which is hilarious. And uh, you know,
he was talking about this girl to
talk shit to him and he's like,
and you know what?
And this fucking bitch was Armenian
like you don't know any better. Like,
like they have like special rules.
I,
there was this Armenian
dude I knew a long time ago.
He's an enforcer for a loan shark and a,
he's in jail now for double homicide.
But he gave me the best tip about
picking up chicks. He goes, when,
sorry in Brooklyn,
cause I'm drinking beer.
When you're with women,
right?
You say yes to everything. If
she's late, he say no problem.
If she don't show up for dead, you
say no problem. Don't worry about it.
You pay for everything you say.
It's okay if she's rude to you.
Even if she hit you, you say, oops. You
know, you just let it go. Yes, yes, yes.
Then the second she say,
I love you.
You turn that bitch around and you
fuck her in the ass and you punish or
followed up bullshit. You put
your through. Whoa. And it's true.
I think that guy's doing it wrong.
He is in jail.
Didn't work at all. And
Actually, oh, post the real jail,
not just jail. Jail. What did he
do? He murdered two people at once.
Double homicide. Yeah. That's
a, that'll put you away.
Yeah. People frown upon that.
It's,
well,
we've noticed a pattern over time since
cave days where when we allow that it
gets worse.
It gets worse and worse and worse.
And that's one of the most amazing
things about human history.
How frequently people were just killing
each other up until really recently.
Yeah. I, uh, I was a at a place
recently, last week actually,
that didn't have a, they didn't have
cable, they didn't have internet,
but they had a stack of DVDs.
And so we said, all right,
well we got here and we watched,
uh, gangs of New York. Right.
And you know that opening scene with Liam
Neeson's crew versus Daniel Day Lewis,
his crew. Yeah. Battling with fucking
machetes and axes and shit like that.
That's not that long ago.
And that movie was hyperbolic,
but there like a claw lady who had the
clause build the butcher was a guy.
Yeah, he did. He was a butcher.
He did have a fucking glass eye and
he probably did kill a gang of fucking
people. Yeah, yeah. Well you look
at life expectancy and you go,
people died really young back
then. But no, I think the,
those stats are skewed by the number
of people who died in childbirth, five,
10 years old,
20 and a fight.
There's plenty of guys that live to 75
but so many of so many people died young.
Then it fucks the stats.
And you think everyone died at 30 yeah.
Stats are interesting like
that, right? Like you gotta
go, Oh, how is that possible?
And then you look, oh, I see. It's because
so many people were murdered. Oh, okay.
Well, it's going to seem that
today. You look at old photos,
like you've got that old mug shot,
uh, who is that? Rosa parks. Yeah.
You're the first guy to guests
that correctly. Oh really? Yeah.
And you see they're all cross site in
them and I she's not, but I realized, Oh,
you run a fucking all out brawl and
your retina got separated from your eye.
And then it was just, oh well I'm across,
I'll look from now on. I lost one eye.
This eye right eye doesn't
work, but that's fine. Yeah.
They didn't fix anything back then.
I have a buddy,
I put this on Instagram yesterday
is a fucking nasty picture.
My buddy got a staph infection and uh,
it became Marissa,
do you know that medication
resistant staph infection. Oh. Oh,
it's disgusting. I knew if a
guy had that so bad. Oh my God,
that's fucking gross. How
deep is that whole? Well,
they had to open him up that the big scar
up the knee was because the infection
was so bad,
they had to cut him open like a fish
and they had to disinfect the area and
drain the area. But it all came
about because his knee was swollen,
so he had to get his knee drained and
he got his knee drained and he caught
Mercer at the hospital and
he doesn't know. You know,
you don't know where you catch it in.
A lot of guys get it from
Jujitsu cause you Jitsu you're,
there's a lot of scratches
and a lot of abrasions.
They actually have specific soap that
they've developed just to keep your, uh,
your skin flora,
your outside skin flora.
And I was talking before the show about
how Jujitsu ruined your back. Well,
it definitely hurts stuff. Stop
the Jujitsu. It's lose lose.
What's the win? You learn how
to choke people. It's very fun.
It's like the most
advanced version of chess.
[inaudible] everyone says that about
every sport. Yeah, they do. I know.
It's like everybody calls chess boxing
his chest. It's like people say,
well that's, that's our version
of the word nigger know. You know,
like they do that.
It's like that expression like gay people
like to say that with the word Faggot
or if I've heard that with
tranny I that with long hair.
These dudes who we did an article
about him vice long time ago,
but guys who were super serious about
long hair and getting through that awkward
phase,
they call it what it's like here and then
someone goes get a haircut and they go,
that's our version of nigger.
Oh that's like our version of being
dragged behind a truck. Oh my God,
I got Jasper,
Texas.
Who behind a truck is pretty much
the worst thing that can happen.
You haircuts don't feel like anything.
Somebody really said that. Yeah,
they should be beaten.
Yeah.
That person should be thrown to
a maximum security penitentiary.
Should be dragging and chores.
Just just have them get their ass kicked
and don't drag them on a truck to the
Diet,
dragging them behind a truck for 15 feet.
Cause that probably kill my kill you.
It won't kill you. But it hurts. Like,
I couldn't imagine your head depends
on how you protect your head, you know,
cause you might hurt your elbow and then
lift your elbow up and then you face
plant and then it's over.
Right. Cause you know how,
how strong are you mentally to let
your elbows just grind down to nothing?
Because once that 15 feet starts, you
don't really know when it's going to end.
I mean they might say they're
going to take you for 15
feet, but you, you know, no,
you have to faith that they don't just go
fucking gas and Oh my God,
I think it might be worse
than drowning. Met 15 miles.
Yeah. It's worse than trousers
being buried alive, buried,
alive. I don't think it would be as
painful. It'd be horrific and terrifying.
Drowning they say is actually fairly
peaceful once you just give it. Right.
It's like there's the struggle then
you give it them. How would they know?
Burn drowned,
burned alive.
Maybe they can test the stress levels
like the amount of genuine dead on the
cadaver or something.
I don't know why you'd bother to do that.
Let's go burned alive.
Top drag mine at Chuck to
drowning three in Canada,
we say buried. Buried alive for
I say buried. Oh, you do? Yeah.
What do people say? Buried? Buried. How do
you pronounce this? Space? Berries. Nas.
A varied NASA. NASA. How
do you say it? Nassau.
Bahamas. Once. Two A's. Why is there a
second day different than your first day?
NASA. That's true. It's
not n a s e h. Hmm.
NASA. NASA, NASA, NASA. But what,
what does some people say but it's
secondary. NASA. NASA, Canadian say NASA.
But why would you say NASA
doesn't know? W you're right.
That's stupid. You're right. Wow.
I'm learning a lot today. Fixed it.
It's weird. It was like black
people love acronyms. Like, uh,
like, like fame stands for,
you know, forget anything.
Me and uh, every one. You
know what I mean? Well,
I think it's a sign of late years when
you get into the word rather than go look
it up. And they'll be like,
library where they keep the lies.
I know that's different and you're like,
why don't you move past just the
fucking word library and get into like
publishing or what gets
published and what doesn't.
I don't need you to take apart the
syllables things. My favorite is fear.
False evidence appearing
real. No, no, no, no.
You should be fucking
scared. This some shit that'll kill you.
I'll tell you. That is the biggest way.
Worse and racism and anything else.
The biggest albatross on black
Americans neck is this vision. This,
this assumption that the
world's out to get you. Mm.
And there's no sense in trying. You can
go to law school, you can graduate Alma,
come latte or whatever it's called.
Uh,
you won't get a law job because you're
black. So they go, well fuck you world.
Like when the Ferguson riots where
there were cops are killing us,
we're fighting back and you go,
cops aren't killing you.
Stop assuming that killed
that one guy. Yes. Sort of.
But that the Ferguson one
was the worst example.
It's weird how examples get picked up
and then people run with like the worst
one. It's like, like Ferguson
was, that was a bad guy.
There was a guy that had just committed
a robbery just before had punched the
cop,
was in a fist fight with the cop and got
shot at close range shot and then then
shot him.
And then people like hands up don't shoot.
Like that became the narrative. Like, boy,
I don't know if there's a lot of evidence
that that hands up thing happened at
all. Not like a thug. I can get
you black guys shot by cops.
I can get you black guys killed by racist.
I can get you black guys who stuck,
stuck with their families and had kids
and got fucked over and her in jail for
no reason. Let's do those guys. It's
not sexy enough. Yeah. But like, oh,
here's a sexy one that don't understand,
didn't take off as much.
Like the Tamir Rice kid
and 12 year old kid, they,
that guy saw that kid for two fucking
seconds and shot him and killed him.
That's got a BB gun.
Yeah.
He had an airsoft gun and the guy who
shot him had a poor evaluations on his,
uh,
on his ability to handle stress,
had a breakdown during one
of his training exercises.
They said he was terrible at communicating
to the point where they didn't think
that he would be able to fix it.
They didn't think they'd be
able to make him a good cop.
He resigned from that police force
was picked up by this police force,
goes on to fucking killed this kid.
Then on top of that, they do, uh,
they have private people investigate
it or whatever groups they have
investigated and they decide
that what he did seemed normal.
Like that was the most recent finding
that what he did seem like he's got a
bunch of kids shooting people with BB
guns in that area and doing robberies with
BB guns. It was an endemic in that area.
I do not know that. It may be possible,
but either way,
you don't fucking shoot a 12 year old
kid within two seconds of seeing him.
I mean, if he's got a BB gun, you
just don't, you don't do that,
that the whole that. But to me
that one is like, oh my God,
you're dealing with a 12 year old
boys playing with a gun, a toy gun.
I don't know whether or
not there was an epidemic.
This is the first time I'm hearing that.
But that makes a little more sense.
But that seems to me like a way
better one to highlight that.
That's a serious man.
Well the elephant in the room with
all of this stuff is black failure,
white guilt.
And we need to explain why blacks are
in prison and have to explain why blacks
are doing badly and to say,
oh,
cops are fucking horrible racist pigs
and America's racist explains away the
failure and then there's no
culpability. And you go, oh,
that's why they're doing bad.
It's our fault.
And then you can get on with your day.
But no,
you're in jail because you'd
committed a crime. Right.
But the problem is like when
crime is all around you,
you grow up in this environment that's
the same as it was 30, 40 years ago.
I had this guy, Michael Wood, who was a
Baltimore cop on the show. And uh, he,
when he was a cop,
he was talking about this area
where they used to rest people.
This is the area where the drugs were,
are this areas.
We had a lot of violent crime and this
place and they found this a mandate from
1970 something 70 something.
And uh, when they, uh,
found it, it was the exact same
areas with the exact same crime,
like they were going over the police
reports from the 70s and you're like,
Jesus Christ,
so we fucking spinning our wheels or what?
Like this is the exact same areas,
the exact same kind of crime.
Like it's never going to change. It's
just a swarm of bullshit in this one area.
These kids grow up in this,
it becomes their environment.
They become institutionalized.
Like it, it becomes their,
their reality and then they're stuck.
And it's so hard to get out of that.
It's so hard for me to empathize with
that. I mean I look at green point,
which is a really poor Polish
neighborhood and it's crime-free,
there's drunks all over
the street passed out.
But it's crime-free you look at any
poor eastern European neighborhood like
Brighton beach in Brooklyn.
And I think of my dad,
my dad grew up so poor that his toes
make me dry heave cause he had his
brother's hand me down shoes
and they were too small.
And if you wear shoes too small,
after an hour you're like,
I'm going to kill myself. But his whole
life was shoes that are too small.
It looks like Chinese foot binding. And
uh, he fought every day of his life.
You know,
we suck with his brothers,
whom he fought every day and he got
scholarships cause he was smart.
But in Glasgow, being a student
is like the worst thing it can be.
So if you have a private school blazer
that's like wearing a Klansman uniform in
Harlem, he said like, you're fucking
shouldn't. And then they were like,
so his nose, he looks like a boxer.
He looks Kinda like Kerris one,
his nose is totally fine. It's got huge
elephant, like, uh, uh, inner tire lips.
I don't know why I said elephant,
big elephant lips and he made tons
of money and brought us to Canada,
raised a middle class family from poverty.
And he never complained about it at once.
And he would have a
million reasons to say,
that's why I fucked up and that's
why I'm in jail. I did go to jail.
But don't you think that
this is an environment like
you're talking about a guy
who lived in a certain area and
moved to another area, like had,
had the courage and had the
ambition to get out of that area.
And it became a thing with
Europeans. I mean, the United States
was essentially founded by Europeans
who weren't happy with Europe.
So these ambitious people that created
this new environment and these new places
and these new immigrants
who, uh, you know,
all got together and they created these
communities like, uh, you know, I,
my grandparents lived in Newark and uh,
you know,
that was an Italian community
that all came over here.
They all came over from the
boat, from Italy. And um,
my grandfather on the other
side came over from Ireland.
But this is like a group of people that
were very ambitious and wanted to do
better.
So they came to America.
Whereas you're dealing with in the
African American community with people who
were slaves, African American,
why don't we say black?
So black community,
you're dealing with people whose
ancestors were slaves and then they are
released and they live
in these environments.
Then you have in places like Baltimore,
institutionalized racism where you're
really not even allowed to sell,
but they did.
They had places where you weren't
allowed to sell homes to black people.
Like it was.
Yeah,
that was then you want to talk about
what the Irish went through all of that.
There's an echo. The last few
lines. Excuses. I don't know.
I think you're in 2015 your lot
in life is who you are and you,
I was actually thinking about you.
I was beating off the other day
thinking about you and uh, no,
but I was thinking about
you socks on or off.
I had to take my socks off
cause I had to just in them,
but I used growing up punk rock.
You laugh at Hollywood and you
laugh at celebrity and you go,
they're all fucking phony losers.
But in my old age,
I'm starting to think maybe these people
are talented. And you were on that show.
What was it? Radio days,
radio news radio, right.
Look at all the other
people on that show you get,
I think you get 11 million listeners.
Is that right?
Probably a little more than that.
No, really insane episode of Hannity,
which is the most successful show
in the most successful network.
I think it's 4 million. Uh,
11 million is fucking insane.
I think Anderson Cooper
gets 100,000 viewers,
so I'm starting to think maybe
Joe Rogan is just a very talented,
like Jennifer Aniston. She was
on that show. Friends, right?
Courtney Cox had her a cougar town thing.
Normally I would roll my eyes at this,
but I honestly was thinking about this
yesterday. I thought, wait a minute.
She went from friends to Hollywood.
Maybe she's just a really good actress.
Maybe she's just really good at her job.
And if you dropped her out
of a plane in Costa Rica,
maybe within a few days she'd have
like a coconut stand and you know,
maybe she was genetically
predisposed to be successful. Well,
I don't necessarily think
it's genetically predisposed,
but she certainly worked on
it. Yeah. But they all did.
Everyone on friends worked at,
I don't think they did. I mean,
Matt Leblanc's got a show now on showtime,
right.
And he has some show that no one
washed away where he's placed himself.
It's some new show. It's
like a, he, you know,
he let his hair grow gray and I don't
know what the fuck he's doing, but,
but the other people on the show,
the kind of,
they made a shitload of money and that
kills ambition. Right? I kind of stopped,
but she was the only one that
really developed film career.
And obviously she works
hard. But if that's the case
with almost all those shows,
it's like one person goes on to do.
And what I'm saying is maybe
that person was very talented.
Like Phil Hartman was on news radio.
Incredibly talented guy.
He would be rich and famous if his fucking
wife didn't blow his head off. Yeah,
no doubt. Unquestionably. But you know,
Phil Guy that was on the show
from kids in the Hall Day,
Foley maybe he's not talented. No,
he's a very talented, but Dave,
he went through a fucking horrible
divorce and is still going through it.
Half the country's divorce. It's, this is
what happened. I'll explain to you. Um,
he had,
uh,
he was married while he was on news radio
and he was making more money then than
ever in his life. And so what,
like 30 grand is episode?
Probably maybe more than that.
I think I was probably making that.
So he's probably making more than
me. 50. Yeah, something like that.
And when they broke up and got divorced,
the judge ordered him to pay a
certain amount of child support bay,
not alimony and a certain
amount of alimony,
but the child child support was based
upon the amount of money that he was
making at the time.
And he had argued that was unreasonable.
And the judge literally said to him,
your ability to pay is,
has no relation to your obligation to pay.
And he's like,
what the fuck does that mean? Like
you, you have an obligation to pay.
I don't care what your ability to pay
if you remove the amount, if you
have a kid, you're obligated to pay.
But yeah, well you're
looking at, you know,
he's making several hundred
thousand dollars a month
and then all of a sudden he
has to pay half of that and he can't. So
he was like, within a very short order,
it was half a million dollars in debt
to this woman who is, in his words,
a raging cunt. She, she was always in
a crazy person. She's just in his, uh,
in his well, but again, alleged I'm
lacking empathy. And, um, Dante Nero,
do you know who he is? Beige
Phillips. Yes. Yes. His Shit
is, and I agree with them.
If your marriage failed, you fucked
up. You're the, with a few exceptions,
like Jim goads wife is fucking insane.
But if your marriage failed,
then you,
your boat sank and you're the
captain of the ship and man,
why did you have kids like Louis
C K he's bragging about, uh, uh,
is divorce and how awesome it was.
And I've talked to friends,
I know all his friends, I don't know
him, but they're always like, well,
she was a nut and she was a rich artist
type and she, she was, wasn't livable,
livable with Hubble. And I go, why did
you come in? Or then what'd you come into?
Crazy bitch. So even the few
exceptions where move, no,
that's what I'm saying. The
ship, you control their change.
If you're a real man you that's
crucial her. But you tend the kids,
people change. Like men change, women
change. You can't control change, change,
but you don't always,
sometimes he just wants a job there
that's saying you have a corporation and
your employees, you know, you say,
Oh, when my employees changed. No,
this is how we're running the company.
You guys have to show up nine to five
and we're going to do it this way.
We're making grapple Grumman's well,
sometimes things,
even though they're successful,
they fail over time. Like Pontiac.
The GTO is an awesome car, so it was a
trans-am. None of them exist anymore.
CONIAC doesn't it?
They should have adapted or not.
You should have made shitty or just look,
you did a good job.
Look at doc Martin Work of art.
Let's get outta here.
Doc Martins were punk skinheads shoes.
Then they were nineties grunge shoes.
Now they're lesbian footwear, and then
they went, let's be lesbian footwear.
We've got to adapt. Let's
become flew bogs. Right? Well,
this certainly you can adapt,
but you might be happier that
you might be happier breaking up,
giving her money and then finding young
girls and you can have sex with like
Lucy Kay is doing it. I'm against it. Why?
That's not the way it goes
and it's bad for the kids.
Okay. That I agree with you that I
agree with you and that's what's worse.
You need to have,
sorry to interrupt you,
but you have to have kids so you don't
have kids. Right. I have three. Oh,
that's awesome. Are you married?
Yeah. Oh, great. With wedding ring on.
The three kids you have are with
the her. Yeah. Well that's fucking,
I'm glad I can relax because every
time I talk about divorce and kids,
especially with people
in the comedy world,
I'm talking to someone who's divorced
and never had kids. Well it's,
it's very common,
but I am married specifically because
I have kids and then this, see, I mean,
I've always said don't get married,
don't get married.
Marriage as a contract with the state,
which I agree with.
Up until when I had
kids, I was like, look,
bringing a life into the world to me is
way more of a commitment than a legal
contract that you can get
out of with a lawyer. Right.
So like that, that contract,
the contract with the child was so much
bigger and so much more involving and I
had so much more commitment to raising
kids. I was like, okay, let's do it.
Like if you want to like if I get
divorced some somewhere down the line,
then you fucked up. Well, maybe not, you
know, maybe it's just people want to move.
No, no. I'll throw in the towel saying
is not while the kids are young.
I mean I'll do everything I can to
not because I just think for kids,
well I say that,
but God dammit.
I know a lot of God damn interesting
people that became interesting.
I'm not going to use this as an excuse
because I'm actually happily married.
But people that became interesting because
they went through childhood breakups
and they moved around a lot.
I mean Mike Tyson is a good
fighter because his childhood
was held and she wants
everyone to have a shitty
childhood so they become good.
Not necessarily good fighter,
but I mean like interesting people,
like every interesting person
than I know overcame adversity.
They went through some crazy shit. It's
a great point. That's a great point.
It's a hard thing. You have
children. Yeah, I got three.
So when you're, you know,
I'm sure you take care of your kids,
but do you think of it like, man,
I'm short of sheltering these children
from the very things that made me
interesting.
A lot of my friends that have kids,
we kind of go through that dilemma.
Yeah. But I got plans for that. I mean,
I don't want to send them, I want to send
them to boarding school. Yeah, for real.
Yeah. Boarding camp. Boarding school.
Really like send him away to go to school.
Every top producer at Fox News
went to boarding school. Okay,
well then don't send your kids
to boarding school. There you go.
You've got that nailed.
I keep thinking you're right wing,
but you're not in some ways, in some ways
I'm, I'm, I'm a very, I'm an outlier. I'm,
I'm a middle of the road and
a lot of like I'm in the NRA,
but I support gay rights and you know,
and a million other things that pro
choice million other things that people
would associate with left wing.
Obviously pro marijuana, right?
Well your normal basically I just
don't believe in right or left.
I think most of it is bullshit and
these ideologies that you still have to
rigidly apply,
you know,
and you originally adhere to the
right or the left and you a, you know,
you automatically,
I had a conversation once
with this fucking guy at a
party and I'll never forget
this, he was talking about
Democrats. He's like, well,
we got to win the Senate because if we
win this cycle, we, what is this? We Shit,
what does this week it? You want a team?
Are you on a team because you're talking,
we like you owe it goes well.
There's a lifelong Democrat and like
you're a lifelong democrat. Yeah.
Do you know crazy Dallas
cowboys? I exactly what people
to be left alone I want.
Yes.
There's two in politics is two groups.
It's people who want to be left the fuck
alone and people who don't leave them
the fuck alone.
And I tend to go right on most
things because the right as,
as of today seems to want
smaller government than the left.
But that's not always true. Like George
W. Bush spent way more than Clinton.
I don't know if I believe that.
I think they just go where the money is.
I think the go with the money is, and
they go with the influences. You know,
we were talking before the show about
this thing that I'm doing with Anthony
Bordain where we're going to,
um,
an episode of his show that we're
going hunting for birds and we're,
we're going to talk about a public land
versus private land. And Steve Rinella,
who's a,
the host of this show,
meat eater who's on the podcast earlier
this week had a really good point about,
um, about politics. He's
like, he said, I'm a political
unit, was his words. He goes,
because you got the left,
which is trying to take away gun
rights so I can't support that.
And then you've got the right
who supports your gun rights,
but they're taken away private land.
They're taken away or public
land that is used for hunting.
They're selling a way to corporations.
And so he goes like, I'm kind of fucked.
He goes, cause then both hand, cause
he's a professional hunter, so on both,
on both sides. He's like, I can't
adhere to either one of these.
The rightest selling land
away to corporations to
what bill is doing is there,
there are many on in the Republican
administration and many on that side that
are supporting the rights of corporations
to either sell away or take away some
public land is right now used,
you know,
there's public national
parks and public areas.
When they find these resource rich areas
that they can exploit and make a lot of
money, then they'll sell
contracts. These corporations,
I mean this is what's going on in
Alaska with when they're talking about
drilling and give it time,
uh,
the free market will make nature
better. I mean, we saw that in Zimbabwe.
Macaby was starving the fucking wildlife
to death and then he started selling
off the land.
They realize that it is in their best
interest to have lions and fucking zebras
and giraffes running round.
So wildlife started coming back and
that Cecil the lion dude was sort of a
result of the free market getting
involved in sort of thing.
But that's a very extreme example of an
insanely poor area. And on top of that,
one of the best versions of that,
there's a Louis Theroux documentary on
these African hunting camps and that I,
you know, I hunt. So I have these
conversations with people all the time.
The way they did it in Africa,
most of the animals that are
hunted on a regular basis,
now we're on the verge of extinction.
All these different like Nealon Elan's
and a different blocks and different
kinds of deer and antelope.
They're fucking dying off like crazy.
But now they have them,
these private hunting camps.
So they have thousands of
them and they're right,
but they're thriving so that people
can go over there and kill them.
Like it's this crazy catch 22 no,
that's fine. You can't do that in man.
It's like the guy found a Greenpeace
who's now kind of anti Greenpeace goes if
you want more forests by more wood
because you incentivize trees,
right?
But in order to get a real good hardwood
tree that's a hundred feet tall,
it has to grow for hundreds of years.
And if you chop all those fuckers down,
you're not going to have any,
not a way that you change the
environment in which these trees grow.
All the birds, a song, birds disappear.
They're nesting areas go away.
The environment completely changes.
Like there's a lot of issues.
You can't just say yeah but like
go in there and North America,
there's more trees now than there ever
was before. And that is a true cut.
More trees and more trees now know
a lot of them are small, skinny.
But that's because we like trees.
We need trees.
I look at like ducks unlimited,
right? Isn't that run by hunters?
So they are doing more for marsh lands in
the government. Ever could. That's true.
Yeah, that is true. So that's
because they want those lands.
Those are public lands. So like
the, the lands that they're,
they're preserving those,
these habitats are public.
So what are these corporations doing
with this land? Like well look, fracking,
fracking is a huge issue. You know, things
awesome. Yeah. Well is it? Yeah. Is it,
it's not awesome if you live down
water from it and it doesn't feel well,
there's a possibility it could pollute
with definitely pollutes water.
This deck does not,
but there's definitely wells that have
been polluted by fracking. Uh, maybe one,
oh, come on man. That's not true.
Yes. Such a movie. Frack nation.
It's one movie was the f quit. How many
fraud? Many wells keep tap water on fire.
That's that water was always flammable.
It's naturally occurring methane in
the water. There's burning springs,
New York and it's my thing.
I saw
they use centrifugal force,
um, that, that water was always flammable.
That's why the people frack there cause
there's methane in the water. Well,
I don't know if that's the
case and it's the case.
It can be that that's the case.
It's risky.
Just like an air conditioner
falling on your head is risky.
Everything has inherit miss. And where I
am in the Catskills, uh, my place upstate,
there's tons of, uh, of, of uh,
perfect land for fracking
and these people, all the
hippies, all the weekenders,
the city, it's as they're called,
I'm one of the ads. They banned it.
Mark Rufallo is one of the big
guys up where I am. Oh, the Hawk,
the Hawk bandit and these kids in my
neighborhood up there RNF Afghanistan.
So they're going,
they're risking their lives to get what
I call unethical oil oil from people who
stone woman to death because
we've considered natural gas.
Some sort of fucking 80% of your natural
gas is already fracked. All of Ohio,
Texas, that's all fracking. Well, it's
certainly changed. The price of gas.
Gas has dropped dramatically since
they started doing that, rack it up.
But I don't,
I'm scared of them polluting wells and
I'm scared of than ruining water supplies
and the,
the underwater underground water supplies
and la in general where me and
Ella and John and I'm a part of La.
That's a pattern I've noticed
here. Okay. Where you go.
Like I heard that you with
Greg Fitzsimmons and you
were talking about teachers
and you're like, the
children are our future. Uh,
they don't get paid enough and
it's Mark Marin's says that too.
I got in a fight with him and he never
aired my, uh, what the fuck podcast.
What's really why? Well,
here's my theory. Uh,
he claimed it was because I came out as
a trans phobe and what's our interview
is now incomplete and it would be weird
to release it without us discussing
trans, wait a minute, wait a minute.
You came out post post
interview as a Trans Phobe yes.
Why is having an opinion on something,
whether it's a negative or
positive opinion, why is
that a phobia exactly. And I,
that was my point. I said, your dad
cutting his cock off, you're scared.
That's scary. Like that would
be scary. You wouldn't be
like, good morning, I guess.
Mom, you'd be freaked the fuck out then
that's a phobia. So we're all transphobic.
So I said Transphobia is
perfectly natural. Well, um,
I think I have you got your shit for
this dude talking about the MMA fighters.
But it's only because of this.
This guy was a guy for 30 years,
became a woman for literally 24 months,
started beating the fuck out of women.
And if you watch the fights, you're not
talking about even a skillful person.
It's just like it's, it's someone who's
just got a completely different frame.
I mean,
the way throwing these these girls around,
but that's,
I support your right to become a woman
if you want. I don't give a fuck.
If you want to know, well, I
do. Obviously I support it.
But here's a big misnomer with
this whole live and let live thing.
Like Anthony Comea says, hey, you
want to be, you want to get married?
You want to be gay going, I
don't give a fuck. Fuck you.
Now that we've legalized gay marriage,
people are getting fined like
a couple in upstate New York.
I find $13,000 for not having a
gay marriage in their living room.
What? I don't understand
what that mean. Well,
they usually host marriages
that there. Oh, they said, no,
we don't want to do this here
because it's our living room.
So I'm a live and let live dude.
And now that gay marriage is a thing,
people are being forced to go
against their religious beliefs.
So it looks like gay
marriages let everyone be,
but it's actually fucking with Christians.
And that's a very rare case, isn't it?
Isn't that a pretty rare case where
someone's having these marriages in their
living room? Yeah, I don't
think you should. I don't
know. You want to talk rare,
the gaze wanting to get married.
He's rare. How rare is it?
They don't want to get one on my block.
No, my, my neighbors are getting married.
These two facts upstate
and, and they, they,
they don't use that word of term.
They go, uh, yeah, just proposed.
And I'm like, oh great. And
then one of our mutual friends,
cause isn't this exciting? And
they go, no, they have eight,
like eight, some eight sims. Oh. Like
I've bragged before. I've had a bunch of,
but in the Hetero world,
that's hot shit.
But to them I'm a fag because you've
only had three sons. Only at three.
We have eight sims all the time.
And I'm like, I can't even picture,
like what are the, your legs go?
Where's the, what is the second column?
Your hair,
it must look like mine.
But with come like he must
have tally towels trick.
They're just holding it in sucking
toes. I mean, even a force him.
Has He ever had a threesome?
Yes. It's hard to maneuver.
You feel like you're walking around with
a clipboard like overrated. You, okay,
how are we doing over here?
It's, it's, it's missing.
The critical aspect that makes sex great
is when you're really into someone and
they're really into you.
Like that's the perfect example.
When you can't get that
prostitution is nice. Second,
when we can get what two people
are really into each other.
Like you're sharing a moment together
and then there's this other person and
we've on me. Oh yeah, yeah. Oh yeah.
I guess how much should I do over here on,
even if you go on a trip with three
people, it's kind of weird. It can be,
but it could be awesome. It
depends on how they gel. I mean, I,
I've had friends that uh,
their wife was a freak and they have a
threesomes or their girlfriends a freak
and they have threesomes and they'd go
out and hunt for girls and they do it on
purpose and they enjoy it. That
must be fun. And believe me,
I would not work for my
wife brought a chick home.
I would not be kicking her out
of bed for eating crackers,
but I've never experienced that. But I
think that my wife fucking lied to me,
by the way, when I was courting
her, she goes, I might be a lesbian,
so don't be surprised
if I bring chicken home
and we're 10 years in where the
checks were, the fucking threesomes.
Well that's a crock of shit.
But the reason you have threesomes
and I guys, if you're listening,
never turn it down, struggle, work
hard, they're really hard to set up.
It sounds like a pop 10 yeah,
I would say I've probably had about four
or five and a good two thirds of them.
I was like a tour manager. Like when are
you in town? Okay, right. Setting it up.
Well, maybe at eight 30, one
of them I had to fake look,
you go to the bar and you pretend that
I know you from high school and you go,
oh my God. And then we'll go upstairs
to your hotel. You had to fake it. Yeah.
So you got to do those though cause you
beat off about them, uh, in your sixties.
Ah, I see. So you're filming it
with your eyeballs taking it all in,
but the actual act itself is
kind of annoying. It can be,
and that's why I was saying to the gays,
they don't,
they're never going to have kids. They're
fucking my age. You have eight Sims,
you take kids and monogamy at a
marriage. What's left? Uh, they,
I think they want to be able to visit
each other when they're in the hospital.
Yeah. That old thing. That's like
with the portion where they go, uh,
what if you're dead rapes? You can
you get an abortion then and you go,
you mean all one time that happened.
Why are we dictating policy based
on this crazy scenario? Yeah.
That's, I think you should be able do
whatever the fuck you want and don't you,
yeah. You shouldn't have to have
lesbians married in your living room,
but if you're gay, you should
be able to get married. Right.
I don't think you should have to go to
a place totally replace half my shit is
there. Bullshitting. What do you
mean they don't want to get married?
It's just as something to
fuck with us. Don't you think?
Some of them do three. Ah,
and they're lesbian. You're
fracking number one. Well,
you know, k's or 1% of the population, say
half of them are less than 1%. It's 1%.
So it's one out of 100 is gay. Yeah.
Like thinking of your classrooms,
how many are lying though?
How many are gay? And they
just, they just never commit.
Is it? So maybe it's two out of a hundred.
Uh, we all know, well, you're gay.
You're gay. Suck a dick. Yeah. But
we all know one closet Osi, right?
How many people? He's a fag.
But this whole thing like, oh,
we like the far right
religious guys going,
we need to get our kids away from
gayness or they're going to go gay.
Suck a million dicks. Margaret Cho
says, she goes, if you think gay,
is it something something you can learn?
Then I got some bad news for you.
You're gay. I could suck one Dick
Right now. I'll suck a dick right now.
You're ready, right. Okay, here we
go. Oh, oh, there's a gun to my head.
Oh, I'm sorry. Hold on. Still got gay.
He just sucked a Dick Right now,
here's my 999th cock.
This guys, I've been a hostage
for two months. Oh, well
I think you'd get way better at it.
I think it'd be more efficient because
you realize if you're more efficient and
you pretended you were into it, it
would go by quicker maybe. Yeah.
It's like when your wife faces
will come quicker. I think that's,
I think that's what's happening
and give a shit if my wife comes,
so how dare you. So, but
you know, if she's turned on
you get more excited. Right.
That's the idea. Yeah, baby. Woo.
You don't people that talk
about women who were bad in bed,
that's like a painter saying
that the canvas has bad.
She's just your canvas.
You have to maneuver and that's no,
no reason why gays and
mucking mind pat and bed,
male and female women can't be bad in
bed. That's not true. Girls were awkward.
They get, they grind on you. We're
they can. You slap her and you say,
don't do that. Can we go and turn
over when you're talking real here?
So like this Mark Marin thing. Tell me
what happened. Okay, so we were in a,
we did the podcast and he,
he's got that La fucking thing where
they fucking thing where it's like,
ah, I'm not going to look it up.
I'm just going to go by my emotions.
Woman politics. Basically. Jesse
Ventura, it's like this too. He was like,
I saw you and Jesse Ventura, the one where
you had your shirt off and he was all,
I see. Yeah. He's like,
what you're saying is people and
other countries aren't as go. Yeah.
Paypal in a mirror. I say somewhat in
Mexico and he goes, Oh, I go to Mexico,
which grade? And I go, Jesse, that's cool.
That's your experience.
That's anecdotal evidence.
I'm talking about millions of people.
I met a black guy who had a Nobel
peace prize in physics. Okay.
So black people are awesome
at physics. Um, anyway,
he was doing this La
thing and uh, he was, uh,
well the problem with education is I don't
think people get paid enough to teach.
I think it should be a more prestigious
position. They get paid 60 bucks an hour.
Who Does? New Jersey teachers.
Okay. One state, no, California.
They get paid shit. They probably go
down to let's say 40 bucks an hour. Yeah,
an hour worked per hour worked.
You get you.
Can you imagine if in your summers
off, that'd be nice. Die of boredom.
But I don't know if that's true.
Like so like while they're in school,
they're getting $60 an
hour. So we're worked. Yeah.
How many hours do they
work at Day Jack? Shit. Oh,
but we have to do a lesson
plans, right. Fucking don't.
You've been teaching that
same class for three years,
but they still have to do
lesson plans, don't they? They,
they've just in autopilot it's karaoke
at this. So what are you saying?
They should get some sort
of an alternative income on
resize it and they should
be, it should be possible to fire them.
And that's what I said to Mary. Oh, okay.
I agree with that.
You said that it's whole systemic thing.
I fucking hate that word.
It's the stomach and there's not just
one thing that can nail it. And I go, uh,
yeah,
there is,
it's called getting fired and in Harlem
they have charter schools now and
teachers can be fired.
They are fucking thriving.
Blacks in Harlem are getting educated
and it's kicking ass and the left is
floundering because they hate, they
like blacks as their little pet victims.
And when the free market helps them,
they go, wait, don't help my victims.
That's mine. And I saw the New York
Times headline. It said, uh, uh,
though charter schools thrive in Harlem,
it's not a fix all.
And the article was basically saying,
not all black kids can go to
charter schools in Harlem.
So they're not that great.
Oh, that's hilarious.
Open up more charter schools
have more than one thing.
It's called getting them fired.
And then it got weird after that.
And he was just reading my Wikipedia
page and talking about shit and,
but what was it? You're trying to find
things that you do wrong? No, it was just,
he didn't want to be there.
So he was like,
what do I ask this guy about
it and didn't want to be there.
So he had shut down after that.
Yeah. Is it? Yes. So what,
what do you think was the trigger?
Just the fact that you weren't willing to
think I nailed him on education and uh,
he didn't like it. You pay, he probably
thought we're not releasing this.
And then he went to Wikipedia like,
Hey, I saw that you did this power trip.
That's a power Marin. Well, that's
doing that and not releasing it.
Like I have conversations where I don't
agree with people all the time and I got
rid of the hill. Well, I don't mind
disagreeing with somebody, you know,
but it's just funny man. The comments
like, people say like, Oh you,
you and that fucking guy fought
like cats and dogs. No, no,
we just didn't agree on things like,
right. I shake their hand afterwards have,
I haven't had one guy,
one guy in the history that Brian Dunning
guy was probably the one guy because
he was so fucking dead in his head.
His brain was so rotten,
he just couldn't, he couldn't understand.
He couldn't grasp simple concepts.
I don't believe in disagreements.
I on something that one guy has more
information than the other guy and I would
just want to get there, uh,
to the right answer. Well,
I also want to see how
you got to your answer.
And there's sometimes is not a
right answer or wrong answer.
It's just this is how you look at
it. And even though if I, and some,
I played devil's advocate sometimes too
much because I want to see what your
arguments are to the contrary. I want
to see what the thought processes I,
every time I've had a
fight with someone they,
and we leave and we're not agreeing
they're wrong and the one they don't have,
they have less information.
And it's happened to me once David
Cross tonight we were doing coke and we
argued for eight hours of just
out David Cross as a coke user.
He didn't coke in the White House. I
think he outdid it. Really explains a lot.
That explains his letter to the cable guy.
A open letter to Larry the cable guy.
Oh yeah, yeah. The desk of he, I
don't think it has coke anymore.
He's old and married.
But this was a long time ago and I was
talking about free lunch programs and I
go, it's fucking stupid. You don't,
lunch is a ham sandwich. The,
I did the math and it's like
a buck 80 right? I go, bums,
get 10 bucks a day to do vodka.
You can't.
You had a kid and you can't
scrape together a dollar
80 for ham sandwich because
the liquid is just the waterfowl. But
it's not the kid's fault. I understand.
But this state can't be supplying people
that dollar 80 sandwich that we have to
have some in supply kids with a little
bit of food at dollar eighties where the
food, you use the argument
in the opposite way too.
If the state can't come up with a
dollar 80 for a kid for a sandwich,
then the state's fucked up. No, I'm
saying it's as crazy as the state going.
We're going to come in and brush your
teeth like we have to give you some basic
things that you're expected to do.
That's like helping kids go poopoo a
dollar 80 the mom that doesn't cost some
money to brush your teeth doesn't
cost money to wash your hands.
It costs money to feed a kid, but that's
where you draw the line with kids.
I can't fucking support themselves.
They're little kids. They don't have jobs.
So if a kid is hungry,
like,
and it all costs a dollar 80 to
make a fight I had with dentist,
it's not a bad fight because I just, I
feel like, look, I was a kid. I was poor.
You know, we were on welfare and we drank
powdered milk and the whole deal and,
and you know, I was hungry.
I remember being hungry.
I didn't fucking rare
in 2015 a kid may be,
this is in the 70s and I know the way
it works in school, even my own kids,
they'd go, do you want lunch or do
you want the school lunch today?
It just became a thing that was expected
and the state has to go at some point.
All right, we've got to draw the
line here. Uh, no. Kids are like,
have hunger pains cause their mommy.
You don't have to be a fucking crack head.
Well there's a lot of people like
crack heads that have kids. Oh, okay,
well then that's a bigger fish to fry.
Now we have to deal with
Chris kids having kids,
a lot of people that are irresponsible
that have children and I don't,
I think if you're going to have a state
school or a state sponsored school,
State's going to pay for everything.
Think about all the shit that's the,
what does that do that for dinner
that night? I don't know nothing,
but while you're in school,
while the kids in school,
you are responsible for that kid for
whatever, eight, seven, eight hours,
whatever it is. That kid goes to
school, this mother is so useless,
she can't scrape together a ham sandwich
and now we let the kid go at three 20
[inaudible] decides to take this kid away.
You could argue the semantics
about competent. She can't fuck,
we have to take that kid away. That's
what I was saying. If your kid,
if you can't supply a ham sandwich or
your kid, I have to take your kid away.
Well at a certain level you got to figure
out like when is someone completely
incompetent, right? It's this a scale.
It's a dollar 80 a day
for lunch and using comp.
I don't think there's anything wrong with
supplying kids with food at school for
free. And I think that if
you, if you look at what,
what needs society should cover,
like which, which is society cover,
should they cover the police?
Should the police be private?
Should they cover the fire department?
Should that be private?
I mean there's a bunch of arguments for
what your taxes should and should not
pay for.
I don't think it's unreasonable if 80%
of public spirals into public schools,
I don't think it's unreasonable to say
that you should provide the kids with
food.
No,
it's not unreasonable to say you should
provide kids who shit their pants with
underwear. But if a kid is shitting
his pants, we have an issue here.
So if a mother can't afford lunch,
sorry, the kids are anyway. Okay.
We have the same thing. But that
was the only time that David and I,
we both had a 100% of the facts and
after eight hours and probably a gram of
coke, we were like,
let's agree to disagree.
That's the only time you ever
agree with the time of my life.
Everyone had all the facts and we
still disagreed at the end. Otherwise,
disagreements are someone who
doesn't understand what's happening.
And Mark Marin was just saying, oh,
they need, uh, there's not one thing.
It's systemic. And it was, you know,
he personifies this sort of fake Beta
male comedian with the Cardigan and the,
Oh, I'm such a mess. I'm so
fucked up. Uh, and these guys,
fuck 20 year old girls while complaining
and scratching their heads going,
I am a mess.
And I was like,
this year we have this narrative of
the jock with the Letterman shirt,
right?
The UVA frat boy date raping chicks.
I'm going through my own Rolodex and I
see those guys cleaning up a drunk chicks
BARF.
And I see the Beta male comedians,
fucking chicks fucking passed out.
Chicks what?
Beta male comedians are fucking
passed out. Checks all of them.
And you know what comedians do like Gonzo
journalist thing here you're like half
serious, half reality, partially fiction.
And it makes your argument's very
difficult to go three your own history and
think of every time you know of a
guy who fucked up passed out chick,
I don't know. And he's not a jock. He's
like, he runs it. He does it. Indeed.
A fucking show. If I know a guy
who fucked the passed out chick,
he didn't tell me about it. I don't know
anybody that fucked up passed out shark.
Well it's usually contentious. Like the
guy I'm thinking of, she was sorta like,
I don't remember fucking him and
I'm never speaking to him again.
But it was kind of wishy
washy and he's not like,
I know these super handsome dude.
She's two guys.
One of them used to be a male model and
this chicken invited them over and she
was,
she got two ways.
So I think she wanted to get gangbanged
and she fucking drank a bunch of oxy was
showing them her pussy at this
point of the story. By the way,
I was mad at him for not fucking her,
but then she started projectile
vomiting cause she over did it right.
And I've heard this story a few times,
especially with threesomes.
Girls get nervous and they overdrink.
And what are these
disgusting Frat boy jocks do?
They washed your sheets,
they've put the towels in
the fucking washing machine
and they made sure she was okay. And then
they went home. These Beta male guys,
like the kind of guys
who are on the Nerdist.
These guys who have one thinks is cool.
Uh,
I see those guys fucking her skull
fucking her or beating off in front of him
and Tom Solusa this to me once he goes,
he goes,
jerking off in front of a
woman is obviously pretty rare,
but it's not that rare in
the comedy world. Well the,
I do know a few comics who have done
some inappropriate jerk him off. Yeah.
They're mentally ill
narcissists for the most point.
And they were this wolf in sheep's
clothing of I'm a Beta male, I'm a loser,
I'm a nut.
And they just use it to fuck chicks over
and dump broads and they're the jocks.
They're the date raping jocks
that everyone's scared of.
Well you're talking about like very
specific guys that are famous and wealthy
and also are playing that role
of being the failure. Yeah.
I'm talking about young
community like Jay more,
but there's two types of comedians.
There's Jay Moore with a dress shirt
and a blazer. That's that generation.
I don't know those guys.
They seem like pretty good guys.
Then there's the American apparel
sweatshirt dudes like the millennial up to
maybe 35 those are the guys
I'm talking about. Okay.
Aren't you doing exactly the same thing?
Is someone saying that black guys are
great at science cause one guy knows a guy
who does something this
year? Theory. First of all,
I'm basing it on a lot of guys. What guys?
Well, well you would have to name names,
but I don't know anybody who's
doing what you're saying.
I don't know anybody's skull fucking
passed out. Girls other than bill Cosby.
Okay.
How many young comedians you know sold
as food data girl at say 26 right?
A lot.
Then they dumped her at 29 her
ovaries are dried up 29 yeah.
I don't think they dropped that young.
Yeah, they do know you can have kids.
Here's your ovaries for the most part,
right?
This is your brain on drugs at 30 the
hourglass turns upside down and the sand
is draining from 30 to 35 snow, sand
and over five you're fucked. It does.
The pelican. Bring your
babies as well, Joe.
That fertility is draining from 30 to
35 my wife had our first kid at 36 or
something. They will go through
a door that said geriatric
mothers. Oh, it's over.
Well there's, that's in Canada. Double
evidence. They die. Young candidate. No,
I murdered in New York since
the polar bears since 99 no,
it of course there's exceptions.
My mother had my brother at 41 but
generally throughout your brother's soft.
We joke about his week sperm,
but uh, I mean we say he was,
he's bred with the old ovaries.
But I realized my youngest
son was born much with a mom,
much older than my mom.
So we don't do that joke anyway.
But even with my youngest son, I was
watching him like a hawk at the beginning,
worried about a autism.
So anyway,
if you date a chick at
26 and you dump it 30,
she's going to take her a couple
of years to get over it. Right.
To the point where she's
ready to have kids. No, nope.
I mean get over it like
the new guy and marry him.
And maybe be ready for kids. Who
knows? Man, I know a girl who,
whatever anecdotal evidence,
go ahead.
If you kill a woman's ovaries like that,
you are not killing it,
but he's ovaries. Yeah,
you're taking her back.
There should be some stigma around that.
That's Hitler because she waved her best.
Those kids would have had kids,
those kids.
So if you did during a time in her life,
30 you have killed a million people.
You have committed a war crime.
You're Hitler. It's very hard to take your
argument. Seriously. You're a funny guy.
Which part is bullshit? All that.
It would kill your Hitler. You, you,
you killed her ovaries.
All the, all the above.
You have denied the world
millions of people. No.
No you haven't because a woman can't
give birth to millions of people.
That's fuck no, but her grandkids,
grandkids, grandkids. Did you sleep?
You could be making billions of dollars.
Million. Look at Attila the Hun.
I think he's responsible for
like 3 million people. Oh,
like physically. Yeah. No, no. Yeah.
He didn't fuck 3 million girls. No,
he fucked a bunch of, he probably
fucked you. Don't have enough hours.
You don't have enough time to come.
I'm talking about kids and grandkids
and we were talking bullshit.
That's what you're doing. We're both
talking bullshit. No, we're not. Look up.
Come on. I'm not going. Are you a
nerd? Look up how many children,
how many children came from
until the hunt? Quite a few.
Not as many as Genghis Khan.
Genghis Khan's responsible for some like
one out of 500 dudes in Asia or some
crazy number. Okay, so
that's what I'm saying.
How many in year seven you take
up a woman's fertile years.
You've done the opposite
of a team or hiking up her
years, her years or going on.
They're going on.
You happened to be,
she found her title after that 32 it's
very hard to have cold round her during
the time where she's 26 to 29 it doesn't
mean you're responsible for her any
more than she's responsible.
You shouldn't be conscious.
Both she and you should be
conscious of this is our prime time.
It's like football players.
Okay. I think women are,
that's why they get like super serious
all those times amongst my sort of media
hipster kind of entertainment people,
that whole concept is gone and one
generation ago it was, you know,
you got to get her while she's young and
this is her big year and blah blah blah.
There was some uh,
value on those formative over years.
Today it's nothing.
And these women,
they get dumped at 30 and then the
women get dumped at 30 a lot of them get
married, but I know in New York got
dumped at 30 wow. That's super anecdotal.
But I think a lot of my friends, when
they talk about women, they talk,
if they date girls that are like up to
25 26 they're more like, they don't care.
They're having fun.
They're there doing their thing with their
career and they're doing their thing,
going on dates and stuff.
But they always say that when they get
to be around 30 31 32 they're like,
where's this going?
That's lanes is heading.
They should be saying that at 27 is
all I'm saying in your world. No.
In a world that doc and doc,
I had some chick,
a friend of mine, 39 her,
her, her physician said, Ooh,
35, uh, getting kind of late.
And she said it to me like,
can you believe that sexist pig? And
they go, he's a nerd. He has Asperger's.
He doesn't have, he's not sexist. He's
telling you about your fucking vagina.
Is that a sexist pig to say?
Because today if you're 30 that's what
I'm trying to say today in 2015 to speak
normal biological facts, I
called them hate. Fax is sexist.
It's sexist to say that it's hard to
have kids after 30 and nearly impossible
after 35.
Well,
I don't know what this has to do with
comedians that are fake Beta male skull
fucks.
Comedians don't recognize that.
You're not responsible for that any
more than they're responsible for
recognizing that you're a 45 year old
guy who's going through some midlife
crisis, some existential angst.
This goes back to what I'm saying,
but no one's responsible for, you know,
control the relationship. And if you,
a lot of these guys will
fuck over this girl.
And sort of imply that he's
going to put a ring on it.
And then 29 30 I mean,
New York has a very disproportionate
number of total though.
You're saying a lot of these guys fuck
over. Like relationships don't work out.
A lot of times people pretend to be one
thing when you first start dating him,
like you were saying,
your wife
was saying, you know, I might
be a lesbian. And then as
you get deeper than you, oh,
that was just like a shiny little spinner
and behind it was a hook. You know?
That's how you catch trout to Troy.
So you're, you're, you're, you're,
you could play it on both sides.
People are full of Shit and
they're full of shit to themselves.
People pretend to themselves that they
are this one type of person because that
person appears to be more attractive.
So when you're talking about these hipster
guys that are pretending to be these
Beta males that are super sensitive
and male feminists, they in their mind,
they have convinced themselves that they
are this thing because this thing would
be more attractive to the type of
women they're trying to attract.
So they're very just as confused.
I agree.
They're not like this fucking
master miles self sabotage.
This mastermind is trying to engineer
this false narratives a trap.
What's negligence when you're just young,
they're living their life now.
They're like 35 they're
fucking a 26 year old.
Then they dry up her ovaries and
they dumper. Oh, okay, let's,
I'm talking about too many different
things at once here, right?
We want to establish,
I want to establish that 100 from 25 to
30 should start getting serious and they
have a certain currency because
their ovaries, two or none.
There's a venn diagram here where they
overlap where if they don't want fucking
95% of the population wants kids.
I don't know about that and what,
I don't want kids, a lot of girls
who don't learn, they are extinct.
We've been over a quarter of a
million years. They just want to talk.
Need to one kid like the kid is this
substitute that Doug is a subsidies and
they called themselves mommy.
But when you get on the four oh
five three o'clock in the afternoon,
he can't fucking move cause there's,
there's no room because all the cars
have blocked up all the road and you go,
maybe we need more girls with little dogs.
Maybe we need more gay guys.
I want to get married. Yeah. Well maybe
these people who aren't having kids is,
is a self selection and you know where
you're going to have annoying feminists.
They're good. My kid isn't going to
have to deal with them. Why is that?
Because they're going to die off. Yeah,
they're dying off right now. I wonder.
Jessebelle won't be around in one
generation. A lot. Doesn't have had kids.
They don't have kids. No one had,
Jessica has kids. Maybe one or two.
It's like fracking. Well no
really? And I actually know,
I used to be friends with the chicken
decibel and she told me that that's not
true. Really? Who, which
one? Tracy Egan. Okay. Uh,
she's a writer. Yeah, she's advice.
Now she told me that, uh, that,
that I'm spilling the beans here,
but I don't care.
She told me that the managing editor
who looks kind of like Jimi Hendrix,
but it's a woman, uh, she, uh,
would cry herself to sleep
at night because she waited
too long and her ovaries
dried up. And, uh, I feel
like screaming at her,
your whole agenda is telling women that
they're men and they don't need kids and
they'll be fine without kids. And you
don't even believe that fucking shit.
But is that their agenda?
Because I don't think it is.
I think their agenda is saying that
women can be empowered and women can not
have to live under the
predetermined directives that
men have set forth them and
they can do their
own shit.
That's was the beginning of the impetus.
The pendulum has swung so far
and now it's, if you do that,
you're a sellout and a loser and
you're a fucking Stepford wife. Why?
So if you have a relationship and you
have a family and modern feminism,
vilifies the Midwestern housewife.
Calm.
Our wives are losers according to
Jessebelle Willie. I've never heard that.
I've never seen that written down. So you
see implied when you read the articles,
it's like she's bad ass.
She's kick ass like celebrating
empowered women there.
Celebrate. Do you believe that? I think
in some ways that's what they want.
They want to celebrate empowered women.
Kick ass too is a movie that sums up
modern feminism and it is women or men.
Women kick ass.
Women are marines like modern feminism is.
Why aren't there more female superheroes?
I don't know.
Cause it's not a feminine thing to fly
to a bank robber and punch him in the
face. And I actually have a
theory about this. I said,
but men and [inaudible] funny,
I've never heard anybody saying that
they want more female superheroes. Oh,
that's a big thing, isn't it? Yeah. Why
don't the, how come the women, feminists,
the women, feminists,
they're the real feminists.
I mean if there are real feminist,
it's only women, feminist men,
feminists are just, they are
extinct of Betas. Got You. Got It.
You got all the same rights were done.
Humanists is really what we should all be.
I don't think they have the same rights.
You think to have exactly the same rights.
What rights do they have?
What rights does do men have
that women don't have? Well,
it's not a matter of rights.
It's a matter of rights for sure.
Like as far as leaking any metric. And
men are worse off rights as far as like,
but as far as like the way they're
appreciated and cultures and society,
certainly now worldwide.
Oh No, no, no, no.
I'm the only talking about North
America or the West fucking Middle East.
All feminist should move to the
Middle East and get to work.
Why don't feminist embrace
like Rhonda Rousey? She seems,
seems like the ultimate feminist. She's
like have like a feminist from a movie.
They don't embrace her.
No.
Cause that's my beef with feminism
is that they're to Ronda Rousey.
Well she is hot,
she's hot and she kicks ass like
she literally is like two mater.
When I see Leora craft,
I don't get a boner.
I get a boner when a woman is feminism
like southern Belles make me hard.
I learned some woman does a back flip
and shoots a monster in the face. I go,
oh it's some dyke has short shorts on
and knows how to do backflips and I think
nerds like it cause they want to see
action and they want to see pretty girls.
So they'd to save time, they make a
tomb raider. Right. So it's like a,
what's that thing when you take a Turkey
and you cook a duck in it? Yeah, exactly.
Turducken I was watching the
movie support your local sheriff,
you know that movies? No. What does that
really look with sheriff? It's like, uh,
what's his name from uh, uh, James can no,
James Caan. No support. Your local
sheriff. Okay. The Guy who was in Hawaii,
five o forever. Oh Jesus.
Well the fuck was that Nervo
near, it's not an insult. Jamie's not
a nerd. I mean, he's apparently not,
he can't look hindered the sense
that I'm a nerd, but, uh, all right.
What is this where we look anyway
in the movie? Ah, there it is.
And who's the main guy? What's his
name again? No, James Garner. Oh,
James Caan. Anyway, in the movie,
there's this scene where
they're in a courtroom and uh,
they're having some trial and this
woman comes out and she's got on like a,
you know, that's wild west dress and
the fucking hair up and little blouse,
quite attractive. Anyway, she gets up
in the court and she goes, hey, Yo,
listen to me and you'll listen.
Well Patna I've had enough
of this and I want you.
And then they go border on the court
can sit her down. She said, no,
I will not sit down. I demand that
you listen to me and I'm watching it.
I just had this fucking epiphany wash
over me and I realize men invented this
bitch. Like men invented
Jessebelle feminism, lyric craft,
this whole thing,
because she's not being feminine.
Like that movie was cast by a dude.
That movie was written by a dude.
They're making her get up there.
And I think the suffragette movement,
the whole like women
should vote was guys going,
why don't you fucking say that you
should vote. And the ladies go, what?
I was making a Lasagna. Now get up
there, say I need to vote, I'm a lady.
And they go, okay, uh, I'm
a lady. Well, you know,
there is a biological reality for women
who have to take care of themselves.
Women who work actually
develop more testosterone,
women who are in the workforce
and we have to compete. Yeah.
They actually develop more testosterone
and they become more aggressive like
because of that testosterone.
And I think that when women are
forced into that sort of a position,
like is it,
is it a coincidence?
Not saying that all
feminists are unattractive,
but a lot of like really
vocal ones are unattractive.
And so therefore they're forced
to take care of themselves.
They're forced to be on their own.
So they're forced to compete in
the workforce and you have to,
in order to survive,
you have to become more aggressive
and so be in becoming more aggressive.
And then in standing up for themselves
and their own gender, they become like a,
an antagonist or they become rather a,
an opponent of,
of the men that they're competing with.
They don't belong there.
They don't belong in the work environment.
Well that's whatever,
the most part by themselves. Okay, so
you're your worker in Maggie Thatcher,
you know this. Tons of Alpha females who
Oprah fucking rock Oprah. She's great.
But my experience has been,
uh,
when the woman contributes
to the workforce,
I'm going to say 80% of the time it's just
like, what does that mean? Okay, I'll give
it a rub in the forehead and goes, let's,
let's ride this out until we can get
back to creating stuff. Like for example,
when I ran an ad agency,
we were doing a commercial for
converse and that bit was, um, uh,
this guy's standing over here and then
this guy walks over and, and he says, hi.
Then he leaves and he's
a hunk and she's a girl.
And then later she talks to
her friends and goes, oh my
God, he talked to me, blah,
blah, blah. So, okay, got it. We'll
do that. And then the woman goes,
and then she comes up to
her friends and she's like,
can you believe what happened?
Her friends, like, I can't
believe it. And I go,
wait a minute, these are people.
And she goes, yeah, well, and I go,
but I thought these were the people of
this world. And she was, well, who cares?
It's just, and then, uh,
she also said that putting weird
things with your hands here,
for the people that are
just assigned to this,
you're walking your fingers along the
table and I don't even know what the fuck
you're doing. And I'm in the room
with him getting drunk actually,
but I go on another beer.
This is the world. Okay.
The people that pull their fingers,
right,
can't just flip it and make some people
fingers and sometimes fingers or legs.
I didn't know this was going
to be taking an audio wise.
Let me give you a better example.
Um, my s my brother Andy percent,
my brother designs
video games. Uh, and uh,
he said when we do a thing with men,
they'll go, oh, okay. It's a squirrel.
He's on a skateboard.
[inaudible] an APP, right, right.
And he gets a bunch of nuts and then you
win a prize. Got It. And here we made it.
Okay, it looks good, but he goes, well,
if I do something like that for a female
client, so they'll go, we had a thought,
uh, what about changing the color scheme
from sort of autumn to more of a summary
thing? And he'll go, okay,
well that's not a button.
We'll have to go back
and change all the code.
So it's essentially making a whole new
video game from scratch. Okay, fine.
And then he'll go, but we'll have
to bill you the same amount again.
And then he goes, they kind of get
indignant, like they go, well, fine,
like you're not going to question
me. What? Cause I'm a woman,
I'm going to have a problem with
that. And then they go, okay,
so my brother will have to Redo the
video game in a different color.
Whereas men would go, oh, it's a whole
other thing. All right, fuck it. Yeah.
That's not some men. Right.
Again, this is anecdotal.
I'm talking about my personal experience,
but so much like just the other day,
this woman,
I have a meeting on Wednesday and this
woman set it up and I've talked to this
other woman and this other woman, I
know this is sexist, but I go, well,
I have a thing at two. And
she goes, okay, I'll just move
it. And I go, no, no, no, no,
no. This is an important meeting. I don't
want these women to think I'm a flake,
so don't change it. Uh, that makes
me look like I'm hard to work with.
And she goes, oh, okay. Uh, I
was going to move it around.
I go, this meeting is huge.
Don't be fucking with the Times.
And I'm just like,
why am I dealing with these chicks when
it could be dealing with a dude who
would just go, okay, well the
meetings only going to be an hour,
so I think he'll make it fun.
Okay. Handshake. Well isn't it?
Don't you think there's some
women that can handle that?
It sounds like it's an incompetent person.
You could run it.
An incompetent dude too. Speaking
generally, right about millions, right?
Women are good at micro
management. They're good at
a line producing for example.
They're great at that. Uh, as far as
big decisions and handshake deals,
men are,
tend to be much better at it.
And my entire career has been
almost exclusively women.
Why is that? Because I'm selling
shit. So when I ran the magazine,
the marketing people, marketing people
tend to be women. The ones buying the ads,
they're woman advertising. The ones who
aren't, you know, bequeathing the budgets,
the ones who come to the set. Women,
women, women. Buckwheat is a great word.
I don't,
I don't know how we got from Beta
comedian skull fucking passed out girls to
this. But I'm trying and,
and men are different. Uh,
that's the big picture.
And feminism is something that's created
by men as a false narrative that women
have bought it, Hook, line and sinker,
where there really should be
at home protecting those very,
very valuable three years from 26 to 29
before their ovaries turned to Sam or
something like that.
That you're being sarcastic because
I'm listening to you going, yes.
Well done.
That is exactly what I still,
I'm trying to figure out what went wrong
with you and mark Marin that you became
transphobic or he transphobic
after the inner, no,
I wrote an article called Transphobia
is perfectly natural and it shut,
shit hit the fan. I read
that and I also saw the, uh,
the video that you put up about these
people regretting their transition. Right.
You know, there's, there's definitely,
there can be that, right? I mean,
that goes back to what we're saying,
what gay marriage and the surface,
it's just leave and be there. They
want to get married and I go, no,
actually people are getting fined for
not having a gay marriage in their living
room. So it's not as simple as just leave
them be you're actually antagonizing
Christian, but no, no, no.
That's just one. And you were
talking about the outliers.
The ones in nipple,
the five have to bake the wedding cake.
You know that whole story about the pizza,
like in the wedding cake,
like they sought out someone who would
say no, exactly. It's fake. Right.
That's my whole beef. What is
faith? It was a store, the Ra's,
but they would try to create a story.
You want the right to go
camping and you go, ah, okay.
But I've never seen you camp before.
But they don't not have the right to
go camp camp blacks camping, right.
Scam. And you go, hey, no one's
suing black people for camping.
Like this is a non black camping ground.
But if they heard about a campground
getting suit, oh wait a minute,
I didn't know it was camp ground
did kick black people out. Yeah,
that would be shut down. Fucking fucked
up. My point is be gay marriages.
They don't really want to
get married and uh, uh,
but they do have a gay couple and
lives down the street from me.
They're good friends of mine.
The thing with trans,
a kid with the Trans was
when you normalize it and
say it's perfectly healthy,
right? Then your eight year old
son who's gay by the way, uh,
says I'm a woman. You Go, we're
going to just ride this out.
And when you become 18,
you're gonna move to the West village.
And we were red leather shorts, shorts
and suck a bunch of Dicks and realize, oh,
I'm a fag. I met a woman. But
now that we've normalized trends,
what we, what these moms are doing,
cause they love having a trans kid,
it's like a status symbol. Now what?
Mom's love having a trans kid. Yeah.
You want to talk about outliers?
Like that's the real outlier.
Not even the people getting sued
for marriage. The moms are a soup.
It's a status symbol now. Yeah. What,
where are you hanging out? Look it up.
Anyway,
so these trans moms are giving
their kids hormones, right.
To Delay Hubert [inaudible].
I did see a video hormone,
really young kid that was getting
their first hormone dose. Yes.
I was like, wow. It actually
the story, because he's a chick,
but when I'm talking
with slightly different,
they're giving them hormone blockers.
So puberty won't be disturbing because
see you of pubes and your Dick won't get
bigger or whatever happened.
Yeah.
So kids are getting hormone blockers
cause we've accepted this as fact that
trans is normal. And then
we're also normalizing, uh,
the operation and their suicide rate.
It's brutal. Now I'm not denying,
there are a few dudes who
are happier with the con,
like Zoey Tur, who's that? I've talked
to him a few times. He's got a con.
He used to be a, he used to be a, a
helicopter news guy. He's the guy who,
who saw o j and the Bronco.
He shot that [inaudible] and he,
she created a vagina and she
seems to be happier about it,
but she's pretty conservative and
doesn't think that operations should be
normalized because it's fucking
weird. You know, it's adorable.
Is that Caitlyn Jenner doesn't
believe in gay marriage. Yeah,
well that's common with trans. They
tend to be conservative. Really? I,
because I think they have this
mental that is very traditional.
Like Caitlyn Jenner didn't turn into a
bull dyke and didn't wear a sweatshirt
with a nose ring.
She turned into like a 1950s lady.
So she has this very traditional
with a very rigid famine. Yeah.
Like it doesn't move very well. Not very
pliable. Cut your cock off by the way,
Bruce. No, he's got to keep
it. Well then he's a poser.
He is opposer but doesn't Bailey
Jay still have his dick, her deck.
Hey, can you say her dick? How can you say
her? That's the problem with this mess.
It come with these new terms. They
like that. Hi Bailey. It is a mess.
Bailey won't speak to me anymore cause
I call him. He really, and I'm like,
so you're a woman? And he goes, well, I'm
not a woman, but I'm not a heat. I'm like,
fuck. Oh Wow. Take a night course
to talk to you. You fucking people.
Have you seen Harvard's new
rules on Z and thigh and they,
they're enough. Fuck New Pronoun.
So Ze walks into the bar,
slam the dude's face and you're like,
was it a chick or a dude?
Like I want to know the race. I want to
know how tall and here, right? H E r h.
E. R. Right? Isn't that
one of them? There's like a
bunch of them x. He was like,
they're just making shit up. See, this
is the key to political correctness.
It's not about justice.
It's about me telling you how to speak.
It's about the upper classes
telling the lower classes. Oh,
you don't say a black anymore.
You're saying a person of color.
It's also about calling out.
It's
calling people out on
their transgressions,
calling people out on using
the wrong gender Pronoun,
calling people out on being insensitive.
It's like looking for greenlights
so they could say that you're wrong.
It's looking for the moral high ground.
That's a real issue with
it because it's a game.
It's a social brownie
point collecting game.
Like you want to be the most progressive
person and you want to be the person
that is the most aggressive
about calling out other people.
It used to be the promotional website,
open minded.
Progressive was like about being like
sensitive and loving and trying to be
accepting of all people.
Now it's become about finding people who
aren't progressive and calling them out
on an outing them and
shitting on their life.
I think it's people that just get a green
light to be a cunt and one of the cuts.
Yeah,
the best greenlight is finding people
that you think have violated someone
else's civil liberties or
civil rights or or you know,
sensitivities and you just
aggressively go after them.
It's fascinating how they act when an
old person like a war vet says Negro,
they have this sort of giggling like
Negro that's so old,
that's like four names ago.
They're not up to date with the names.
We've been telling them and they go negro.
Then it's black.
Then it's African American.
Now it's person of color.
Has the United Negro College Fund still.
How do you have NAACP still?
How do you have real
association for Advancement of
Colored People? They go like,
like I was on Fox wants in.
This woman said that Hillary said a
colored person and what Hillary actually
said was person of color and she was
mortified, uh, in the green room going,
oh my God. I said, colored person.
I meant to say that Hillary said person
of color. Well that's what should I do?
I'm like,
why don't you apologize to them right
now because there's some black guy sound
guy over there. I'm like, go apologize
to him. Maybe he'll forgive you. Well,
isn't it hilarious though? Think
about what you just said. I mean,
if you didn't know this language
and if you didn't know human beings,
how ridiculous is it that it's okay to
say a person of color but is not okay to
say colored person that is the same
crew fucking this is all bullshit.
I agree with you on that. Like at my
boxing gym, all the black dudes are,
and the Puerto Ricans and the Hispanics,
there are really good thing.
There are all the white
people get brain damage.
They're all riffing on each
other's ethnicity, like, well yeah,
you're Puerto Rican. What
would you know? Go on welfare.
It's a fun way to ref and it was the
way it was a generation to go with the
Archie bunker's on the doshas is fucking
Polack and I believe that we were
closer when we could make jokes
like that and relax and be like, oh,
it was on island time. Look at the black
eye when I discipline New York. Disagree.
I disagree with that because
I don't think we're not,
I think we are closer now than we've
ever been before, but I think these,
these issues that we're dealing with,
these are like transitionary issues and
I think that as people become more and
more aware of each other,
those will start to erode and
be outed as being preposterous.
And I think these kinds of conversations
where we're mocking this like national,
like the the colored people
or a person of color,
these conversations are important and
I think ultimately people will come to
their senses or at
least come to this show.
But I disagree that I think I'm scared
of women at work. I don't care to women,
period. I don't write, don't riff
at work. They turned the sand. I uh,
they fucking hate man scribe ovaries.
You fuck with people and you can't
take it how you want to be clear.
I understand. Got It. The whole
way. Black woman at work. Okay.
We had some black women and I was scared
of them because I thought this is a
woman double whammy.
And the black women right at work,
they don't like that they're a pariah.
And you know,
you're in the lunchroom riffing and going,
look fag,
you like hot dogs cause they're Cox. And
then a black woman walks in and they go,
uh, hi, uh Shinika how are you?
And everyone is walking on black
woman eggshells. And that's not fun.
And I don't think the
black woman like it either.
Everyone was having fun until
I walked into the lunchroom.
It's hard for me to get into this because
the black women that I know are all
black Comedians,
right?
Black Women Comedians are the black
women that I know from work. Rather.
I should say that's so they're fun,
you know, so it's like Tiffany had it.
When I say we're,
we're better off when you could riff.
I'm talking about Middle America.
I'm talking about Archie bunker.
I'm talking about a cubicles and
the lunch room and the water cooler.
And I believe that all this
political correctness has
just made white people say,
I'm getting away from them.
They're not worth the trouble.
They could ruin my career if I say the
wrong joke. Well, that is a real issue.
I mean, if you, if you're
dealing with, it's super,
super fucking sensitive people and you
have them in the workforce. You, you,
you know, if you, if you have a company,
sorry for doing that over and over again.
What was that woman that sued, uh, uh,
famous tech woman who sued some company
and they said she was really hard to
work with really?
And she lost,
she lost a lawsuit because she said it
was about sexual discrimination. Uh,
all women in every company.
Miss Woman,
she went on to work for
Google or reddit rather,
she went on to work for Reddit or
the Asian one? Yes. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Didn't she can phone, she ran
reddit or something. She, she, she,
she didn't run read it, but she was one
of the CEOs. Right, right, right. Um,
I guess that is run
reddit. Right. But she uh,
she sued for Ellen Pao.
Right? That's her name.
I think she a black
husband. Okay, good for him.
They're wanted for all kinds of fraud.
I think she learned the hustle from
the black husband and he said, oh,
just bitch about race and a, it's tons
of money. She was bitching about race.
I think she was bitching about sex,
gender discrimination. But you know,
they were trying to say that this,
this is not a good person.
She was not a good person.
And that was like the whole argument
behind like having someone like that is,
is inherently dangerous. Like
if you had, not her in specific,
but having someone who's like looking
for those green lights like we were
talking about, like with progressive
people looking to find something, some,
some made up transgression that they
can call you out a lot of the time,
sorry from a drifting. But a lot of the
time these women in the workforce, uh,
subliminally recognize they shouldn't be
there and they need to generate income.
So they come up with some sort of
grievance and it's the grievance industry.
And I was watching TV in the hotel
with my wife this morning. Uh,
uh,
we don't get to watch TV because we have
kids and they don't like the TV being
on at home.
So I'm just fucking bingeing on reality
shows and hot rod shows and everything.
And she got bored and
went to see your friends.
And I thought the reason she's
bored with all this reality show,
like I was watching food factories when
I watched food factories and they're
showing how you make jam. I can
imagine, oh, I see what they did there.
And I can imagine driving the truck
that is harvest the berries and I can
imagine inventing the machine
and I can see the screen.
The screen is probably the best way
to get out all the twigs and shit.
And I'm watching like my guys do my shit.
And I see that when I look
at a building I'm like, Oh,
you had IBM's there and you built a strong
foundation. Obviously it's 84. So I am,
and I think women don't see the world the
way we do. And it's the same with kids.
Like I'll take my kids to the park and
I'm playing with them and I'm chasing my
son around and as a monster, but a lot
of the Times after maybe 20 minutes,
then I go, this is getting fucking
tedious. Uh, I'm sick of being a monster,
but my wife has a unlimited patients
when it comes to being with the kids.
So generally overall I'm not,
obviously there's exceptions,
but I think men are better at creating
societies and women are better at
nurturing. And I just keep
seeing these software types of,
what about these angry women? You
know, angry feminists or what?
You don't want them raising kids, right?
You don't want fucked up kids. Well,
what is by these angry?
You're talking about a handful of cons,
but what's happening is these women,
like my wife,
instead of meeting me and having
three kids, they're going,
I guess I should be in the workforce
cause men or women and women or men.
So she goes into the working on some
stupid converse idea and everyone is just
sitting pinching the bridge of their nose
going, yeah, that's not going to work.
We can't use rollingstones music in a
commercial. It'd be like $3 million.
You know what I mean?
So what he's saying that women should
totally rely on men. They shouldn't.
Another thing relying on men,
look,
you fucking made three human
beings come out of your con.
But what if they didn't?
What if they didn't?
They didn't have to find a man in order
to get by. Oh, I see what you're saying.
Well first of all, I'm, I would never say
women aren't allowed in the workforce.
I'm talking about this huge contingent
of women who have forced themselves into
the workforce and don't like it,
and especially even moms with kids.
I keep seeing my friends
who have working moms, uh,
getting messages, texts. I've
even seen emails where they go,
I'm fucking miserable. I
hate it. Like Nina Simone,
I saw this Nina Simone documentary and
they talked about how late out, well,
the implication was she was lazy,
but how miserable she was with
her and I'm watching going, no,
she's depressed because she's on tour
in Europe and she's not with her fucking
kids. It's unnatural. Well,
not in that sense. Yeah.
If you do have children and you're not
with them and you're touring somewhere
that, especially if you're a woman,
that should be really depressing.
It's depressing.
It's depressing for me.
If I go on the road for a weekend
and I don't have my kids, I get,
I get bummed out for two
days are pretty good.
I third day you start missing.
Fourth Day sucks with women.
It's like my wife, we're,
we've been gone for 24 hours.
My wife won't let me say things.
My son says cause it'll remind
her it's like a topless wow.
Like he says put down me. If I said put
down me right now to her, she'd be mad.
Right, I understand what you're
saying. Um, I don't, I it's,
it's,
it's real hard when you get into these
generalizations like tests because women,
if they don't enter the workforce,
then what do they do?
They wait around for some
guy to pay the bills.
And when the problem with like the
idea of saying that like working moms,
I agree that a lot of women wish they
didn't have to work so they could take
care of their kids.
But then they're looked in
disparaging ways by then and you know,
talked about in disparaging
ways by men who are like, well,
you don't even contribute
to the household.
Well those guys are fucking
assholes and fuck them. And I,
I don't understand this whole, I need
to work. I don't, I can't afford it.
When I was a kid, we were middle class
and if you had that, my childhood today,
you would be below the poverty line.
Like we had one car,
my mom would get the groceries on
Wednesday after my dad got home.
We didn't go on vacation much.
We didn't have babysitters
that I didn't have a car. Uh,
and it was a perfectly happy life.
But there's this,
I need to get into the workforce.
You need to get in the
workforce to pay for the nanny.
You bought yourself into
a higher tax bracket.
You need a car to commute from work.
I think that it's a zero sum game.
You probably bring seven grand a
year to the family where you live in
Williamsburg. Isn't that like super
expensive? It's fucking insane.
Like how much is Benjamin costs this?
In the past few months I ran the numbers.
I've been spending $780 a day.
We blew 50 grand since March.
On what?
There's no culprit. I like booze.
I'm an alcoholic. That's $40 a day.
The babysitters and angel are you and I
need a holiday? Yeah, definitely. Yup.
How many days do you tried to take off?
I quit boost for lent.
I didn't have drinks on, I just became
Catholic. I would go up [inaudible].
How old are you? 45 what the fuck's wrong
with you? Why becoming Catholic now?
I had kids. I was, I believe. I realized
that there's something else going on.
That's why I want everyone
to having else going on.
What a cult of child kid fuckers. What's
what's going on. I was raised Catholic.
Oh really? Yeah. I've been
in that shit when I was weak.
Those child fuckers are called gays. Yeah.
They're called priests too, and they're,
they're, they're running the
Catholic church by the way.
Okay. You know about that,
right? That kid fuckers run
the Catholic church. Yeah.
I think there is a problem in the
Catholic church with pedophilia is jai and
problem.
Right.
A massive probably literally is a cult
of kid fuckers for Nascar had as many
drivers. Fucking kids. It would have
been closed down in the 60s yeah.
Well the whole Middle East
should be shut down. Yeah,
but you're joining in on this, why you
joined and why are you giving them money?
Then they pass the tray round.
Do you throw 20 bucks in their thinking?
I hope this goes to kid fuckers.
Uh, no, but to be totally frank,
I realized there that there is a god
and Catholicism was the nearest thing to
grab. I mean, Amen. God. Um,
how did you realize this?
Uh, well first of all, I think that
religion should be a little more private.
Like my wife, I don't know
what her religion is. Well,
it's very convenient when people want
to talk about religion and say religion
should be private because then they
don't have to defend ridiculous ideas.
Religion is a ridiculous idea.
Oh,
by ancient by this idea
that makes no sense.
No one ever like my wife's
American Indian, right. No
one ever top American, sir.
You mean in Digitas?
Indian feather, not dot.
And I don't know what her fucking
religion is. She never talks about it.
If someone dies, they do fucking shrooms
and sit in a teepee for three days.
That's my kind of really doesn't talk
about it. And no one ever criticize.
Like with Indians, you can't go in a
teepee if you're menstruating. Right.
No one ever talks about that there cause
they don't want the bears to come in
and kill everybody else. They don't have
to justify their, their spirituality.
But for some reason Christianity is,
is like on the chopping block everyday.
What about this on page three?
I don't understand it.
He has to defend it because there's
a book, you just said it yourself.
You don't know what they believe in.
Kind of this kind of interrogation.
The Koran,
and we'll get this kind of interrogate
tour is not filled with things that you
would say are magic.
What is magic in the Torah?
What's magic terrorist towards just the
Jew Bible, but what's what they don't,
they don't believe that
Jesus walked on water,
came back from the dead
or are healed sick.
I'm not that well versed with the Torah,
but I assume as a religious
tract it's full of whimsical.
A superhero.
He's sounding style.
You have to be able to defend the
hoses in the tour. That was magic.
He split the sea.
Well,
I don't know if that the parting
of the sea was in the Torah. Is it?
Yeah.
Well,
the thing about it fascinating cause
it kind of brings it all full circle.
The mainstream Jerusalem scholars
now believe that Moses was on drugs.
They believe that Moses was in,
it was taking psychedelic drugs and
that's what the whole burning Bush was.
The burning Bush
represents the Acacia Bush,
which is a very common plant in that
area. And uh, it's rich with DMT.
So they think that the burning
Bush was them smoking DMT. Wow.
Which is the most potent
psychedelic drug known to man.
And it also gives you all of these
experiences where you feel like you're in
contact with some sort of a higher power.
So they think that
that's what was going on.
I use of hallucinogenics also helped
get me here, uh, in my teenage
years. But uh, yeah. Why did
you join the Catholic Church?
Uh, it was the nearest one. I,
I'd like the Knights of Columbus.
I joined the knights of Columbus.
I'm a third degree night. Uh,
but what made me really
believe in a daddy,
and I don't know why I'm telling this,
but I was coming home once
and my kid was in her crib,
my first kid and I was looking
at her heel and you know,
a little baby's heel and I'm like, that
thing fucking works. There's a bone there,
there's the tissue.
It's got padded tissue below the bone.
And I'd always suspected
there was a god deep down.
And then I just sort of
washed over me and I went, oh,
I get it now.
The Big Bang was some sort of omnipotent
force that created the first domino and
that domino fell and
everything followed after that.
So the Dodo bird is not like God
went and killed the Dodo bird.
He set up this almost like that movie
where the dude drinks the drink and turns
into sand and goes into the
waterfall. Oh yeah, yeah,
yeah. Um, uh, fuck the uh,
the Prequel to alien. Yes.
What the hell is that permeates almost
like the beginning of Promethean. They,
that massive, incredibly complex domino
was set off boom with the big bang.
And that me and my daughter's seal.
Wow. That's convenient thinking.
You know, it's, it seems like a guy
who calls out bullshit all the time,
but then just buys the into that.
Like, it's not about evolution.
It's not about random, you
know, got successful. Okay.
Evolution is God. Well you,
when you say God though,
do you mean like a guy who created every,
like a specific individual or shitty
little teeny brains trying to wrap our
minds around this incredible thing here,
I'll prove to you that exists. Okay.
Don't you think that Catholicism
represents our shitty
little brains that create
these ridiculous,
pathetic attempt to grasp the infinite by?
But why join into that?
Like why become a person in all the life?
Like I go to a Latin mass and
I'm in this unbelievable church.
I don't understand what they're saying
is speaking Latin and it's kind of cool.
It just recognizing the miracle that is
birth and I'm just so thankful that I'm
here and the infant's decimally small
odds that I was created and I'm just sort
of saying, wow. Uh, thanks. Do you
do the same thing with science?
Do you go to like the Hayden Planetarium
and do the same thing when you studied
constellations? Sure. I because you think
I think the earth is flat because no
pro science.
What Catholicism is gallows pretty pro.
What the fuck are you talking of?
All Galileo.
Galileo just kept poking the church
until they eventually said fuck off.
You're under house arrest. They,
they never really denied that.
The universal holders on the son.
This is not true at all.
They fucking put him under house arrest
cause he was insisting that the earth
was not the center of the
universe. Right. But he wouldn't
shut up about it. And they eventually
sent some crop, right? Yes, he was right.
So they locked him out in the Catholic
Church and fuck, he's Filipino too.
Well don't even defend up today here.
How about Ratzinger?
How about the fact that they own the
fucking biggest gay by they own a building
that houses the biggest
gay bathhouse in Europe.
So you would be okay if I was a member
of a different Christian religions.
All religions are ridiculous.
I think ideologies are ridiculous.
Daddy is you're against day as them.
You're against them against predetermined
patterns of behavior that you
subscribe to that are thousands of years
old that were written by people who
were extremely ignorant to the facts that
we know now is to how the universe was
formed and how biological life has evolved
and all of the work that science has
done.
That doesn't mean I don't believe in God.
It doesn't mean I don't believe in the
possibility of there being some grand
order to this,
but the idea that the Catholic church,
the guy who dresses like a wizard and
sits on a fucking golden throne and you
have to call him father,
that that's the guy that this is,
this is that you're trying to
represent us. That's US trying to,
we're doing a really shitty job.
I mean this is, this is a really,
really ancient shit that didn't make
any sense back then and they were,
that's all they had.
But now that we do have science and we
do have so much more knowledge than the
people who were writing this shit down
in Qumran and fucking animal skins and
leaving them in clay pots for people
to go over and decipher this is,
it's, it's ridiculous to
know. It's an idea that uh,
enforced me to a double homicide.
And you said the,
at the beginning of the show and you said,
we've learned over time,
it's been a pattern here with murder.
We don't like it.
The Bible was an amalgamation of
all these stories where we went,
here's some things we've learned. Uh,
killing people sucks. Don't do that.
And it's lasted for 3000 years.
That's longer than catching where
two different types of cloth.
That's really bad. Yes, it's not perfect.
There is some weird shit in there.
So a lot of weird shit in there guys come
back from the dead and the heel. Okay.
Do you believe that a good definition
of infinity is if you had monkeys on a
typewriter forever,
they would eventually print out
the completed works of Shakespeare?
I think that that
definition of infinity is,
is a very strange one because the
idea that you would have these monkeys
randomly typing on a typewriter and
they would come up with the exam.
There's no evidence that that's possible.
There's no evidence that it's possible
that a monkey just slamming their fingers
onto a keyboard would type out words in
perfect grammar with periods and commas
and question marks.
It could possibly be.
How about a computer that is just randomly
hitting randomly printing out keys?
It's certainly our infinity, would it
not? Eventually in a trillion, trillion,
trillion, trillion, trillion, trillion,
trillion years happened to have printed
out the complete works of Shakespeare.
It,
it could be possible,
but I've seen no evidence that it's
ever been able to be replicated.
Even in a simple sentence, but
you'd never seen evidence. It's, but
there's what we're talking about.
Something like that.
Something that's never been
replicated even on the tiniest scale.
Yeah. It has been replicated in a
tiny scale. It's called hacking.
You keep trying the password
and eventually the computer
after 3000 tries cracks
your password.
Yeah.
But they'll work on complicated
algorithms that were created by people.
Like this is not good algorithm to have
random texts punched out on a keyboard,
but it's not random.
They're there testing it.
Like when you were talking about
like a monkey typing on a keyboard,
the monkey doesn't understand language.
So monkey's using semi colons and the,
and the proper form using like three
periods in a row and then a space,
but doing it over and over again to
form the complete works of Shakespeare.
Like I guess I get it, I guess I
get it. Okay. But I don't buy it.
Let's start with that.
So you get it.
So we are next to an infinite universe.
That's monkeys on a typewriter.
That means at some point there's
got to be an earth or uh,
a planet like earth. Right.
More than that even. Okay, good.
Right? Then you go, wait a minute. If
I'm doing infinite possibilities here,
there's going to be an earth where this
is happening. Joe Rogan. Not only that,
the infinite means is the universe is
so big that every single thing that has
ever happened on earth in the exact same
order has happened an infinite number
of times throughout the cosmos. That's
because you're talking about infinity,
where you're talking about something
that literally has no boundaries.
So if there is one,
the possibility of there being an
infinite number of those things exist.
You sound like a, not only that, my
next step was going to be science.
There's Joe Rogan interviewing a
guy that's exactly like Joe Rogan,
but my name's Gavin McInnes, but looked
at it like you, yeah, that's happening.
And then you go, wait a minute. Sure.
Why does it have to be 2015 in October?
Maybe it's 1936 and you're talking to
me on an old timey bullhorn, right?
So why does that mean in a minute?
That is mathematically true.
I know for a fact mathematically that
Joe Rogan is interviewing me with an old
timey bullhorn in 1936 earth
way the fuck out there.
And I look exactly like you, right? I
know that to be mathematically true.
I only have three topics,
two equals four and I have three Cox.
But I also know that that isn't true.
I know that that's not happening.
Well you don't know the show Rogan's not
interviewing me in 1936 how do you know
the planet?
How can you say that?
The fact that those two things
are simultaneously true.
One and the other is proof. There's
a gun. Wait, what do you mean what?
I don't understand what you just said.
Don't shake your head like that.
You fuck you didn't say it God damn
thing. How do you say no, that's not true?
Two is four and I know deep
down two and two is not for.
I know and you know you sound like
a religious person give you that.
You sound like a guy who
should go to church crazier
where it's 1936 earth. You're interviewing
me in a bull horn and I look like you.
I'm saying all possibilities
in an infinite universe
could possibly be happening right now.
All possibilities,
meaning if earth exists and if we do
have cloth in the form of curtains and
again, cameras at work with LCD
crystals and a little tiny statue of,
of biggie small that that's
possible everywhere. If it,
if it exists here and
the universe is infinite,
that means you're dealing with hundreds
of billions of galaxies, right?
With hundreds of billions
of stars is happening.
We don't know coin flip a coin 10 times.
It's probably going to be a pretty
even distribution of heads and tails.
If I flip a coin for three months,
there's going to be one of those crazy
on Thursday there was a time I had heads
60 times in a row.
I don't know.
Maybe now when you go to
the infinite universe there,
every possibility has to have happened,
right, but we know it didn't happen.
What is, we don't know. It
didn't happen. How can you say
that? We don't know. Rogan,
Joe Rogan. Gavin's. Dot. That's nonsense.
We have very little evidence about other
planets at all the evidence that we
have. We've collected all
this data about planets.
We're looking at the gasses that
they admit in their atmosphere.
We're looking at the wobble at
the stars around them. Uh, have,
we could see that there's something
that's circling the stars so we know that
the light changes. We don't, we
don't have a view into those planets.
We have a view into the planets in our
solar system in a very limited way and
well, we're just now getting to the,
we're just not getting to Pluto.
We're learning how fucking weird Pluto is.
We haven't gone at all into the
Kuyper belt. We don't know anything.
The galactic shelf outside
of our solar system,
there's all sorts of shit out there.
They think there might be a brown dwarf
star that we can't even see that it's
way, way, way outside of Pluto.
We're trying to figure out why
there's certain things out there,
why the Kuyper belt is filled with all
these objects, why there's a drop off,
what massive body there might
be deep into our solar system.
And then you go into other solar systems
and other galaxies. This is a fucking,
they've, they've barely scratched the
surface. If you to say that, you know,
there's not a Gavin out there who looks
like me with three dicks sitting in
front of a 1930s microphone. It absolutely
could be true and it could be true.
It could be billions of light years away.
Well, we'll never be able to see it.
That is a great argument against atheism.
No,
you're sitting there saying there's no
god, not just as crazy. At the very least,
I've reduced you to as crazy as me,
and it's nothing.
Nothing has to do with religion. There
nothing, nothing has to do with Josh.
There's nothing magical,
omnipotent force or
science or the science.
What's the scientific explanation for
the Big Bang? What started this mess?
No one knows that. That's a
good one. That's a big miracle.
And what did the Bible say?
There shall be late. Well,
Terrence Mckenna said if science grants,
if they ask for one miracle, they
say, grant, that's one miracle.
And we'll explain the rest of the
universe. But that's just because of,
it's a lack of information.
It's,
they don't know whether or
not the big bang is even true.
There's a lot of scientists that believe
that it could be possible that the
universe exists in a constant
state of expansion and compression.
The same way the tide's work the same way.
There's cycles of breathing in and
breathing out that the universe will
expand and do some infinite direction.
Then come back and some infinitely small
place. This is why I believe in God.
That's why you believe in a cult of
child fuckers that give you bread that's
supposed to be the the flesh of God.
Drink, drink my blood. There's one,
a sad human attempt to act
out what you just described.
Religion as a sad human attempt
to act out what you described.
So what you're saying
with the traditions are a,
maybe I shouldn't say meager meager,
a humble attempt to grasp what
you were just talking about.
I think it's rigid ideology.
I think it's rigid ideology that they try
to control behavior and they want your
money. People shouldn't go to church
until they're 30 because when I go there,
I just see all these nice Old
Lady Sang, God bless you. Well,
that's not looking at a big building
like Jason Jones. You know what?
Jason Jones from the daily show?
No, Samantha Bee's husband.
I don't know her either.
Okay, so he was saying,
I wish there was a religion I could join.
It wasn't religious
and I think Bob Bowdon,
Kirk's kids go to a fucking Jewish
school where the rabbis are atheists.
So that thing exists, but
okay, after we agreed on that,
that that would be a cool thing because
that was back when I was an atheist.
I go, Jason, I went to this
thing, it's called church.
Like they don't talk about gays and
dinosaurs. They just say, God bless you.
Oh, and you're in. They're
going, thanks that I'm here.
Kaison dinosaurs in abortion don't
come up. You just sit there going,
Jesus Christ, what a miracle
we're here. I'm so thankful.
I'm so thankful that, well that sounds
all positive. That sounds all positive.
But the idea of like subscribing to this
ideology and doing it because you want
to somehow or another put order to
something that doesn't have order.
I don't want to put order no or I'm an
all of the chaos. It's like an all room.
Okay and that's native
American religions too.
They sit there and they give thanks to
the north. They give thanks for this.
Thanks to the east to the West.
All religions are the same.
Well I think sank furnace Muslim
religions because they have such a severe
problem with inbreeding that
they've gone backwards in time.
He just did it again. Huh? See what he
did. I see what you did. They're done.
If I'll look at it,
ran in 1965 and look at her and
now they've gone backwards in time.
Well a lot of that has to do with a war.
A lot of that has to do with all sorts
of fucked up shit that's going on in the
middle of the marriage through
his cousin is what it has.
Our are really relying on them for oil.
There's a lot of shit going on.
Line in the oil well,
showing them how to mine oil and
then paying them tons of money.
Well that's also created.
These oligarchs created these monarchs,
these people that have insane amounts
of power and wealth and control these
these areas. Let's crack then if it's,
if you hate it over there so much.
I just don't want to ruin our earth.
I don't want to ruin the natural resources
of our planet, of our, of our country.
I don't necessarily that,
I don't think there's anything good about
giving these people insane amounts of
money or that there's anything
good about relying on them.
I think also we're dependent upon fossil
fuel so much that we've innovated and
that's this one direction
and such an extreme way.
I find people like Elon Musk pretty
fucking fascinating because he's trying to
figure out some way to do it
in a different way to find
out a way. The left goes,
no, I don't like that. I feel like
when you want to Bitch, oh the left,
like we get a pint of left
Canada Fox News here. Yes,
we get a pipe that goes from Canada
down here. How's that? Uh, no,
it would kill a bunch of owls.
Okay. How about we, we, we
frack here? No, no, no, no.
Okay. So you want us to continue
dealing with these fucking inbreds well,
we have done some really stupid things in
the past that have ruined environments.
That's the same. What's, what's Chernobyl?
That's what's going on. And it Fukushima,
there's a lot of different areas of this
country that we could point to all the,
the, what was it? Love Canal.
Was that fucking one area
that the Poise Mile Island?
No, no, no, no. There was a, there's a,
there's been quite a few of them then
and then of course safe all the nuclear
tests that they've done. I
love that one. Animated Gif.
We see all the nuclear tests throughout
history and all the ones they've been
disliking up in Nevada, Dah,
Dah, Dah, Dah. If you're seeing
that. No. Oh, it's amazing.
It shows you nuclear tests
throughout history and you know,
you see like the first ones in the
forties like boom, like Whoa, boom.
And then somewhere around like 1950s,
1960s,
they go crazy. And in Nevada, they just,
just over and over and over again,
racking off thousands of nuclear
explosions and that, you know,
that's how John Wayne died.
That was how the hulk was created.
I don't think that's true.
The whole gamma rays is a different thing.
But it was in Nevada at a
test site, was it not? Well,
I think it was an experiment with gamma
radiation that went wrong. Look at this.
This is the thing. This is a, an
animated Gif file. And if you look,
it shows the dates and then around
1940 [inaudible] 1949 now this,
this is where coming in late because,
uh, why don't we see these Jamie,
there's one. Boom, Sophie, this is late.
You started it late time lapse of every,
so we're in the 1950s now.
These are the United States
ones have already gone off.
What's a matter with this?
If you look at the time, uh,
up in the upper right hand corner
explosions, well, what's a matter with it?
Well, with it effectively Google,
boom, boom, boom, boom. Well,
they're blowing up shit in the ocean.
They're blown up shit.
But there's a lot of those areas that
are just extremely toxic now. Like,
like Chernobyl, chilled nearables
a fucking mess now the communist,
but we have to use nuclear weapons.
It ended World War II.
The Chinese, you know what?
The Chinese, the Japanese,
you know what they were doing.
You got to read this book, uh,
the Rape of Nanking broken. You know that
Angelina Jolie movie? No, she ruined it.
This guy,
Lee,
uh, Louis Zamperini, she ruined it. Yeah.
What about the people that wrote a book?
Now the book is awesome. The movie blows,
right? But did she write the script?
Oh, it was her baby. Oh, was hers.
She created it.
She did the movie of the book.
I want to get back to mark
Marin eventually. Okay. I
hate a lot of famous people,
but uh, he said when he
was a pow in world war two,
the reason I brought up Angelina Jolie's
cause I was gonna say, if you here,
if you're interested in unbroken,
please don't be discouraged
by the shitty movie.
It's a fucking unbelievable book.
Where this pow was stranded on a fucking
raft for 35 days. He beat up sharks.
He got in fist fights with sharks.
Anyway,
in the book when he's a a Japanese pow,
he saw Japanese women and
children being trained to fight.
And this wash of doom came over
him cause he goes, oh my God,
after we kill all their men,
there's still gonna fucking fight.
How are we ever going to end this war?
Or they're going to go right down to
the woman and children, four year old,
we're gonna be fighting four year olds
before this war is over. And then Kaboom,
Kaboom lit the whole island on fire.
Horrible bombs.
I'm not pro nuclear guy ended the war,
but isn't there a lot of evidence there
were already willing to surrender and
that we didn't want to pay any attention
to their children is not surrendering.
Yeah,
but that's just survival.
I mean it just anecdotal evidence of
training women and children doesn't mean
that the country wasn't willing to give
up. They were starving. I mean there,
there was embargoes.
They were in a real bad place.
There was evidence that Japan was willing
to surrender and then we just fucking
bond them anyway.
Yeah,
we bombed them cause we wanted to make
a point and we wanted to test out our
shit really well, I'll have
to look into that. This,
there's arguments on both sides obviously.
Cause you're talking about something
that took place 70 fucking years ago.
It's a long ass time.
But I think there's arguments that can
be made that they didn't have to do that.
Can I get a bucket to Piss in?
Yeah,
we can go piss this a bathroom right
out there. Don't worry about it man.
Don't worry about it. We'll
pause this pitch. All right.
He's a fascinating guy, isn't
it? Yeah, it's uh, it's,
it's cute cause like he's fucking
around. But in these, not fucking around,
it's like a sort of a,
it's sort of like a low rent
Gonzo journalism thing he's doing,
but he's sort of,
he has like real opinions and then he
fucks around when you challenge those real
opinions and says like really brash
things that he doesn't really believe.
Very Fox News Ish.
I don't think it's Fox News,
but I find it fascinating that
all these right wing guys,
they have to be religious.
It's a part of the protocol.
You have to align yourself with people
that will blindly support you or we'll,
we'll,
we'll take you in if you were like,
you have to be religious like Steven
Crowder, religious, Milo, Yiannopoulos,
religious,
all those guys they have in common
that they represent the right and it's,
I don't necessarily even buy it. I
don't, I don't think they're really,
they're really subscribing to it.
I think you have to align yourself with
people that liberal blindly support you
and that's like one of the best ways to
do it. That's how Reagan got in office,
right. Lined himself with
the fucking religious people.
That's how he got in there.
I don't know. There's this,
all Canadians think that America is run
by Christians and then I moved here and
I saw a bunch of atheists,
but running the country,
well they have to say they're Christian.
You have to brush.
Obama doesn't believe in God. How
do you know Christian? I can tell.
How can you tell him? Look at his
eyes. The black. I could smell it.
Really? Yeah. You think he's gay?
Uh,
I have heard that rumor.
It doesn't really wash,
but I do believe a lot of conspiracy shit.
Like what?
I don't think his birth certificate.
His real real,
I think only one of his daughters
is his birth daughter. What? Yup.
I'd never heard that one yet.
You got to talk to Charlotte.
Have you ever had Charles Johnson on the
show? Yes he is. He's a silly boy. No,
he's a great guy. He's a,
he's a nerd beyond nerd. He's
a robot. He's such a nerd.
Right.
And his research is fucking amazing.
Well he definitely does.
A lot of reading goes after people
because he says some preposterous shit.
Like what? What the thing about
taking out deray Mckesson,
he didn't mean shoot him.
Doesn't matter the way you say it.
It was like saying it like that.
When you say something like that,
how much would it cost for
someone to take him out?
Like you have to be like really specific
when you say something like that.
And we were talking about a
marginalized figure. Who's a, uh,
you know, and maybe people would say a
civil rights activist. He should've said,
take down, take down even. It's weird.
How about look up dirt on him. Be Real
specifics to what you're looking for.
This is nitpicking. Yeah. Maybe I got
some gossip. You want some gossip? Sure.
So I was uh, I do a show on
Anthony Caminos network. Right.
And uh, uh, I was going to be on race
wars with Sherrod small Kurt Metzger. Huh?
No, I hate oop for what
he did to Anthony. Well,
what it opie do nothing. You mean that
he didn't support him? Yeah. Yeah.
And they should,
they should have left together.
Their contract was at least put up a
bit of a fight or at least call the guy.
Yeah. Well I think a series probably
offered them a lot of money. Right.
And he has a wife and kids
and this is what you do.
Internet thing was not serious.
Offered me a ton of money and I got
wife and kids. I know what you do.
You do exactly what the Jeremy
Clarkson people at top gear did.
You just step back.
Everybody,
when Jeremy Clarkson got in
that fight with the PR producer,
a top care and they fired him,
punched the guy after a 12 hour shift,
lost his temper,
James May and a Robert with the
books is it was the other guy's name,
whatever, they, they, they
stepped back and they went,
okay, uh, were the show's over.
We're not doing this anymore.
We're not doing it without them.
And they decided that they recast top
gear and those guys are now doing their
own show with, uh, the,
uh, Amazon network. That's
fucking awesome. It's great.
I wouldn't even ask that of, Oop, I
would just say at least try. Like,
I had these friends who,
you know,
we're always trying to get pilots made
and trying to get shows on the air.
And uh, this guy did like a funny
news show and they didn't like,
they liked the concept of show. They
didn't like him as a host and they'd go,
well, how about you as the host?
And we were all friends and he goes,
they want me as the host and it's
his show. What should I do? I don't,
I don't know what to do.
I go fucking call him and
present the situation and go,
this is the deal. They're not going to
hire you talk opiate. Fuck no talk at all.
I don't think they spoken since watts.
So when Anthony got fired,
that was the last day spoke. Yup. What
he just thought, fuck you. You fucked up.
I don't need this shit. That's what
I finally, yeah, finally. Yeah.
I think he was looking forward to an end.
The,
there's some fights on
youtube where there's a one,
a show where he was like
chewing grapes, I think, uh,
and he wasn't paying attention or Anthony
wasn't listening or opioids chewing
grapes. I can't remember what the
details were, but oop. Loses his temper.
And he goes, this isn't gonna last
forever. We're going to, we've got, uh,
maybe another year or so, but we're
done. Yeah, I heard of that one. Yeah.
And I'm even fine with that, but just
call the dude and go, I'm done. You know,
we live in this shitty society where
people don't fucking talk to each other
anymore. Even, even my anarcho
punk friends crass, they,
they penny Rimbaud, they're gonna
start a crass. He goes conflict.
We're getting all kinds of royalties
from our songs and w fuck them.
We're never speaking to him again. And
I go, did you call Collin from conflict?
And he goes, no, I just, I mean that's
why I hood. They'll give him a call.
It turns out they had a crass cover on
one of their live albums and technically
they should have been giving the
royalties from that side of that.
Why didn't you fucking call them? Anyway?
Um, that's a very specific instance.
I know. So race wars, so race
wars, there's going to be on it.
I am going to be on on Wednesday
to discuss exactly this, but uh,
I get this text from curt is going to be
so pissed. I'm bringing this up again,
but uh, it said, hey man, do
you have some oop shit going on?
And I on Anthony show a long time ago,
I don't feel strongly,
but opiate all it really, I am actually
very new to open Anthony. And I said,
I just noticed as a new listener,
every time there's a fun
riff going with Jim and Anne.
That's funny cause they're funny guys.
Opie would come in like a
chick and just go, yeah,
well you shower and I'll show her
right guys. And you just hear the,
the vibe cold brew and
it would ruin the fun.
And I called him a torpid slough
meaning a slow slough, even slow.
Torpid torpid [inaudible] I've never
even heard that word. It's a great word.
Thank you.
I'll add that to the vernacular.
Torpid and luxurious are great ways to
say [inaudible] what does lugubrious mean?
Same thing. Slow. Yeah. Why
not just say slow, slow.
That sounds like English
language and I want to expand it.
That's why I hate it so much.
The massacre at everyday. Um,
so, uh, that's a beef I
have with Opi guests. Right.
And by the way, with, as far as beef,
I'm sure both of us personally
feel like one molecule of contempt.
Okay. But if you asked me
about him, that's my opinion.
It's like my opinion on Macy gray,
not my cup of tea. The singer. Yeah.
Like I don't have a beef with Macy gray.
I just think she sucks.
I don't even know her songs.
Black one. She's just one
really good song. Yeah. Yeah.
Choke. Oh Wow. Hey, don't buy an add.
Shulk oh yeah. I think she abandoned her
kids actually. Freelance career here.
Are you just making that up? No. Maybe
the NERC could look it up, but the nerd,
how dare you. Maybe just super cool
guy gets laid a lot. Can look it up.
But um, anyway, Kurt goes, do you
have some weird beef with the ob?
I think we got to, we gotta
cancel. You what? Yeah.
And so I, we gotta cancel you from a
podcast. You have a beef with opie.
Why would he do that?
To save his job,
to say the shop and then Sharana
Stan [inaudible] how's it saving?
Is His job? Because it's on opie
radio resources on opie radio.
Ah,
so then Shirod call.
That's why you should be on a
fucking network right there.
Cause I have people on here that are our
enemies with people who are my friends
and I'm friends with both of them. And
they have fucking beef with each other.
I'm like, Eh, like dom Irrera and dice
clay, they fucking hate each other.
They're both friends of mine.
That's good radio. It's, I don't,
I don't take sides unless
there's something like if
he's just arguing like this
guy sounds dumb or that guy either has
to be some reason like you have to have
done, it has to be some
transgression that I can't accept.
You know where I say I have to put
my foot down, but it was just, ah,
this guy sounds like a chick.
Or the exception is it's
this guy threatened your
wife and kids or something.
It's a felony or you were
a rat or [inaudible] you
steal jokes or there's got to
be stealing jokes. I actually, my,
one of my favorite things on the Internet
is you confronting Carlos Been Sia.
That's what you do. You fucking go to
the guy and go this joke, this joke,
this joke, this joke now. Well with
that guy it kind of had to be done.
But when you have people like that,
that's a reason to not have them on like
that. Makes Sense. Like there's this,
even Carlos been, see, I'd,
I would imagine today him on this show
that would be fucking, what's his name?
Did he vantage, I'm sorry.
He's so dumb. If you had them
on, you would just be like,
oh, this is just fluff. Come to get him
out of here. Then he leaves like there's,
uh, uh, what's his name? And
you have to deal with them.
This duty was on opie and
Anthony once who lies, uh,
who locker Mexico.
And he was talking with some threesome
that he filmed and with a fitting Beta
tape. And they're like, where's the tape
then if you filmed it right. And, uh,
he didn't know because he was lying.
And then they just go
get the fuck outta here.
And he leaves and it's a fucking great
clip. And then they tore up his book. Yes,
yes. Yeah. But anyway, um, she goes, yeah.
And then Shirod who's sort of the
Alpha male that show goes, uh,
he goes, every time I do is an
invitation to him. He says it's Slavey,
so I won't do it. Slavey yeah, I go, I'm
Canadian. We don't do slavery shit. Uh,
he goes,
Nigga,
I did ob didn't cancel you and Nigga
give a, I can send you, I want it.
And I go, why? And he goes, I
wanted to be more informed and I go,
then text me and go, did you threaten his
kids and wife? And then I would text. No.
And then you go, you're on an
accusation. No, but I'm saying, oh,
that's a reason to cancel. So find out if
it's the big one. And then if it's not,
say let's have it on there.
And the same thing happened
with Jim Norton on Opie and
Anthony back when it was
opie and Anthony.
He was doing a show with vice and I was
scheduled to be on and he bumped it and
I called him now Jim, Jim Shriner.
And I love, by the way, I'm sorry,
I'm fucking talking shit.
Awesome dudes.
But this is just a thing that I think
someone did wrong. I mean Uj walking,
it's a Georgian. Shouldn't
Ajay won? Um, so Jim goes, no,
I want it to be informed
before I had you on.
And we fought for an hour and a half
about this and I couldn't get anywhere in
the air. It was like that David
Cross thing about free lunches.
I couldn't move forward.
It was just, and I go,
how can you fucking
believe that informed what?
You always have a dossier on every guest
and you understand every facet of their
lives. You didn't want me on cause you
had a vice show and you didn't mind to
jeopardize it. He goes, no, I didn't want
you bringing up some beef with someone.
Advice that I didn't know about and I'm
like well then have it out on the air.
Well not only that,
how about just do a little research.
I mean how long does it take
to find out and ask you?
I had a guy on my show who
believes the earth is flat.
I had a guy that's been fucking
said to be youtube clips.
He's angry and they made a hate video
about me cause I deny that the earth is
flat and he finds in consistencies
with the space station photographs.
Hilarious huddle theory.
I think it's called adorable.
Clearly it wasn't informed on
puddle theory when I had the guy on,
clearly I didn't go, well actually the
Antarctica has been explored in the 1936,
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. I was
like, so what's this? The earth is flat.
And then we discussed the flatter
and what did the guys say? Well,
can I watch that? What's, what's
the episode? Or You got David Webb,
uh, down the rabbit hole.
Deep down the rabbit hole guy.
He has a podcast on standup. New York
is a rabbit hole, but rabbit holes,
the earth is flat. He's one of
many people who believe this. Yeah.
It actually made him believe in God
because he thought the Great Creator made
this series of puddles. Wow.
There's a series of Sherwood.
He's long gather and talk about 1930s of
microphones and dude's to three dicks.
Jesus fucking Christ. So what,
what is the beef with, with Vice?
You guys started to get like a,
Shane Smith is a good friend of mine,
but we never easy though. Yeah, I liked
that guy. Okay. How dare you. Okay.
I like him. I like him. He's, he's, uh,
I mean I grew a love him. How about that?
I hug them when I see him really? Well.
He's a sweetie. I think that, uh, he, uh,
he's not a friend of mine. Um, but
uh, you grew up together. Yeah.
When did it go wrong? Uh,
oh six. What happened?
I think it was, I mean, I, I legally can't
talk about it cause I sold my shares.
So I did a nondisclosure non
disparagement thing, get paid.
I got fucking incredibly paid. I make
great money since then too. But uh,
uh, I just keep hearing things about him
and I go, really? People believe that.
Like I got this story recently.
Oh yeah.
When I was in the Bosnian war as a war
reporter, uh, writing about Tito and, uh,
I thought a lot of these war journalists
are lazy. And I'm like, dude,
you weren't even there.
And we're reporters.
Producers died reporting on that war and
you're talking about them like they're
human garbage. Yeah. Udacity. And
no one ever looks it up. Charles C.
Johnson is one of the few guys
who looks it up and goes, you,
you weren't fucking there.
You never worked for AP.
I don't know anything about
that, so I can't comment. Well,
when I hired him as a salesman in a,
after we started the magazine,
I never thought I'd be talking about him
as a journalist because he never seemed
to have any kind of interest
in it whatsoever. But well,
his videos of him going to
all these different places
are fucking extraordinary.
He got admit that I've never
seen him. Really? Yeah.
You should watch them and then
maybe comment. Okay. Yeah,
that and as far as he goes, I can't
say anything about him post. Oh wait,
cause I've never seen anything
he's done or any problem was,
everything that I've seen
is post oh nine okay.
Everything I saw was post
me starting this podcast,
so we're not contradicting each
other here. Yeah, yeah. I don't know.
I don't know what he said before,
what he's saying now, but I said this,
this is how we sum up most splits.
Like I was talking to Jill Abramson
from the New York Times, you know her,
she was executive, I knew her name. Sure
she was ousted. But uh, how dare they,
I go, it comes down to beers, right?
Like you weren't going out for beers
with Pinch Arthur Sulzberger the,
the head of the New York Times
and she goes, yeah, basically.
I mean that's what all these splits come
down to is we stopped liking each other.
We didn't go for beers anymore.
Opie and Anthony,
we're going to have his stuff anymore.
Friends.
That's what's so great about the Japanese.
They insist on beers and when you have
beers with someone that you work with,
you and the Super Hot Honk,
uh,
you establish that you're both human
beings and that though you disagree.
I hate when BLTs aren't
toasted too and it just,
it's like a reboot of
the humanity of people.
Emre I had doubled my wife and kids,
you know,
they didn't and we stopped hanging out
and then any excuse was a reason to,
to split.
So you agree to disagree on what?
On that?
No, it was a horrible divorce. It was
lawyers and tons of horrible shit.
But I'm saying that was the
impetus is it's that simple.
It's not like there's some sort of big
secret like I fucked his girlfriend.
Or do you wish that you
were still involved in that
because you started it and
now you see it grow and it's on Hbo and
it's this huge fucking thing on mine.
It's massive. The only way I could,
I always ran 100% of the content. Uh,
I was the boss of that and they did
sales. So how, how did it happen?
That chain became the boss? Well, as
we grew bigger, we were doing mergers.
And I think,
you know,
your salesman has power because he's
bringing in the money so that salesman can
start exercising that power,
uh, if he wants. And so,
you know, he, when he said, fuck you, all
of a sudden it had this big influence.
And when I said, fuck you back,
it became lawyer things. But, uh,
for me to still be there,
I would have to be subservient to
my previous employees in a sense,
like my salesman,
my herb Tarlek,
it'd be Johnny fever asking herb Tarlek
if he could play a song reference that
I'm, I've come struggling to keep up
with. I kind of remember Johnny fever,
but herb was the guy of sales guy.
Okay.
I remember her garlic and Les Nessman
have taken over w Keroppi and you're
saying to Johnny fever, would he like
to come back to wk RP you Johnny fever?
Yeah. Who else am I going to
be? Bailey. Maybe the chick.
Was it Loni Anderson?
Yeah. Loni and Bailey.
I was the chick.
I was the secretary of place.
But vice is a totally different
animal now, right? I mean,
it's just massive multimedia conglomerate.
I don't know anything about it.
I F I s that's gotta be so weird.
It's a house of cards. Uh, but
you name it, I don't know. Yeah.
We were called Voice of Montreal. Suroosh
named it. Les Nessman named it. And,
uh,
it was a tax scam that
these black Haitians were
running and they just kept us
as a golden goose,
pretended it was his multicultural
paper and they got their money.
And then we realized, I think
after I hired Shane that, uh,
they don't want us to generate income
because they just need us to be this tiny
little bubble that they get
paid to promote. You know,
there's all this money in Canada to
promote multiculturalism and them, right.
So we,
we're a multicultural paper,
but we wrote about
skateboarding and punk bands,
just people are just paying the
money. Yeah. Never read the,
it was a newsprint tablet.
And so how did it become what it is now?
So we left and to avoid litigation,
I said,
let's just change the name device
from voice. Right. And, uh,
then we made up this lie where we said
the village voice in New York threatened
to sue us.
So we had to change the name to survive
and Canadians fucking salivate over any
David and Goliath story involving America.
So it was in everything.
It was in all the magazines,
all the papers, coast to coast,
America's bullying Canada again. And
no one looked it up and after you left,
so this is 2006, that's when it took
off. You had to be like, what the fuck?
I left to know eight,
uh Oh he left.
No eight things started
getting rocky and I was six.
We have the salesmen takes over a company,
it's going to become more profitable.
I mean, my, my sort of not just
model hospitable but bigger. I mean,
not just profitable, but the, the
reach like what it's accomplished.
The stories is sucking off a dude. Like
she's, she's, she's doing really good job.
That's what I'm trying to get to that
woody Allen movie and husbands and wives
when they go, I saw your ex wife, she
was with Liam Neeson. She looked great.
Is that when you found
Jesus? Uh, let me see. No,
I found Jesus and no. Five. Oh,
any coincidence that that's when shit
started to go bad at 12 months later? No,
I mean, I've never been very public
about my religion and Right Day ism I,
I don't even know how it
came up in this podcast.
I honestly get uncomfortable when it
comes up because I feel like we're talking
about my for skin or something.
I'd actually really comfortable
talking about my foreskin. Yeah.
What I was saying. You feel like
you're talking about your forces.
I talk about my wife's asshole talking
about religion is like talking about my
wife's ass. Interesting. Yeah. Hmm. So,
but now when you see vice on Hbo,
do you have to like flip the
channels or do you watch it? Uh,
I've never watched it.
It doesn't come up.
I think it has come up once in a while
when I'm scrolling and I just keep
scrolling. Do you, do
you have a feeling like,
like seeing a photo of an old girlfriend
name? I don't like those guys.
So you know, it's like an x band. Right,
right, right, right. I don't enjoy it.
I'm not enjoying this actually. You're
not enjoying this show. Well, no, no.
This show is great. But this topic.
Okay, we don't have to talk about this.
I love Anthony.
Anthony's fucking awesome.
I think he's a national treasure
is such a freak. Great Guy.
But you know what he has
in common with David, uh,
is 50 year olds are kind of done.
Like they have their shit that they
like to say David David Cross. Oh, okay.
They have their shit they like,
and they're not looking for buddies and
they don't want nuggies and they don't
want to look. He's a Wedgie.
You know? Like I like, I'm a
buddy guy. Right. Thank you.
Farther than you didn't say safety. Right.
I said, slut, I get to slap you. Uh,
so with Anthony, I'm like, all right,
we're part of the navy bodies now.
Fucking Canadians. Uh, let's be buddies.
And he's like, no, I'm an old dude.
I like watching Fox and, uh, play with my
cat. So he doesn't like to do anything.
He's not as,
I don't know why I thought we'd become
best friends after I joined the navy.
We're hoping. Yeah, that's what you wanted
to join for. You wanted a bestie. Yes.
And it's saying, I did Adam Carolla
show and same thing after I was like,
all right, so we're getting wiener
dogs or what's the deal here?
And he's just like bye and walks out of
the room. And I'm like, wait a minute,
I will never get to be best.
Nobody gets to be besties with Adam.
Adam's got his own little group going on.
He doesn't want to hang.
Well he has 50 different projects
going on simultaneously all the time.
You know that Chi has TV shows,
he's got fucking,
who knows how many God damn
podcasts he runs simultaneously.
He's always racing cars and
he doesn't have any time. No,
but 50 year olds have established that 50
year olds get to a point where they go,
uh, I wanted to have 50 shows
and a racing car and I'm good.
And then you show up and go, are
we best friends yet? And felt like,
can someone get him out?
He's so you really,
you really need to make
friends at the church.
Isn't that like part of like
what's good about church?
Every time I've been to church, um, the
people around me are losers. That's weird.
I wonder if to think the same old ladies,
incredibly obese, hideous people. Why?
Because they're desperate and they're
looking for some sort of liberals. I mean,
that's the reason most comedians are
liberal because liberals don't have rules.
They're like, I'll take anything.
So all artists artists are liberal.
What do you mean then I'll have roles.
Well,
like think of how Liberals
and Conservatives see
painting conservatives go,
can you draw a hand?
Does it look realistic?
Liberals are like put a Tampon
in a teacup. You get an a plus.
So creative people tend to be left
because the less crime take you Robert.
Maplethorpe yeah. Um, so that's,
that's hilarious. Well, it confuse
me for a long time because I thought,
why are so many comedians liberal?
They're analytical people by nature.
They investigate shit.
Yet they're all pro Bernie Sanders.
He wants to take your money away.
Didn't you look up how much money
rich people have and what the debt is?
I think they're trying to find an
alternative to what they think is a broken
system. And they don't really
investigate it deeply enough to,
to realize that what
Bernie Sanders is saying,
like financially doesn't seem
to be possible. Like I don't,
I don't think I've seen anybody
say that the numbers jive. Yeah.
But they don't look up the numbers.
And I like someone was saying
to me about you, they go,
he's like a smart dumb guy. And I
go, Huh. He know he's a curious guy.
And that's what interesting people are.
They're curious.
And most comedians are curious
people. SMART, curious.
You'll look at this, I'm going to
seal off. Good. It's weird. It's,
does it make sense? Maybe it means mind
elaborate subjects in a blue collar way.
Okay. But, uh,
I don't get how people can be comedians,
which means curious and
not have looked shit up.
You could drain Warren Buffett and Bill
Gates and all those guys. Bank account.
It doesn't take a pube out of 18 trillion.
How have you not googled that?
You fuck heads. Well, not
only, and it not take a pee.
Like I think if you tax every
single person in this country,
um,
that makes $1 million.
If you tax them 100% you
don't even come close,
right?
Yeah.
Every single person like you would
take all of their money that they make.
It doesn't come close.
This is why I don't like arguing with
liberals and I prefer focusing on my
disagreements with people on the right
cause at least they've done their fucking
homework. Well, I just say I don't
like rigid ideologies. Like I said,
I don't like the idea of
a liberal or conservative.
I'd say I think people lock themselves
into these ideas. And then this is as a,
like I said about my
friend who was a Democrat,
like we've got a win if we win
the sand. Like what, what is this?
What are you saying? I go, what's this?
We year you are in, you know, you're,
you're rooting for the Raiders.
Right? Know there really
is what it is. But if you,
if you say no conservative, uh,
we're a nation of immigrants
or something like that, some sort of
cliche thing, they've already heard it.
So many times they go, actually, uh,
we're a nation of citizens. And uh,
the borders were open in 65.
Listen to what you just said.
If you say that to a liberal, it's
this. If you say I had to conservative,
they do this. That's not my experience
with the left. They say things like, uh,
well like you and Greg, you
go, teachers don't make enough.
You hadn't looked up how much
teachers make. They don't make enough.
It's still not enough money.
60 bucks an hour isn't enough money.
We agreed that it should be private
because I think that when you have things
private and you can make
people fired and you know,
you give contracts to companies
that are competitive, you,
you got a better product. Right. I think
capitalism does work in a lot of ways.
Charter schools are great and charter
schools make less charter school teachers
make less than public school teachers
and they're kicking ass and they get
fucking three months off a year.
They go home at three 20. You know,
board. You'd be if you work that
little, I would be, I would look,
if I got off work at three 20 that would
mean I'd have to go there at seven.
I'd be fucking tired and I would be,
I would be looking for a nap,
easiest job in the world.
But my point is I don't know that I
find with the left when I bring up shit,
they have never looked it up.
Like you say to them,
how many illegals are in the country?
They have no idea. You say, uh,
education needs more funding.
How much does each student get as far as
how much we spend and what goes to them?
The answer is about 12 grand.
About a thousand bucks a month.
They never have any idea. They always
say, uh, it's not enough. Whatever it is.
Or with immigration, I go, how
many immigrants can be taken?
And they go more than we have now.
And you go, there's 30 million,
what's a good number? 100 million.
And they go more. And I'm like,
you fucking hate math.
That's why you're a liberal.
You just like the idea. You're basically
a woman you like. I'm not saying you,
I mean liberals in general.
They just like the sentimentality.
Like I this we're immigrants by
a nice to Mexican male liberal.
No, I don't think so. What am I? I
think you're mostly a libertarian. Yeah,
I would probably say that
I'm a libertarian for
everything but open borders.
I don't understand why they
want open borders. Well,
because we feel like the people in
the other countries got a shitty deal.
They got a bad roll the dice and they're
stuck in this really roll the dice
evolution as a roll.
The dice evolution from Mexico,
Mexico sucks cause of Mexicans.
What have they contributed to
society in the past hundred years?
Exact Ito's that's what Paul J.
Fox said when he was challenged.
He gave us a Mexican innovation from
the past hundred years and he goes,
the TACO delicious food.
He's got a point. Yes, it is.
How about Sombreros? Notice in
California when I bring up Mexico,
people get uncomfortable
because it's like Mexicans.
I love Mexicans and the Mexicans we have,
by the way,
it's power are the funny ones.
Northern Mexico, you know,
different regions have
their different things.
Like in Britain the Scots are known as
funny for some reason northerners or was
funnier. Maybe it's colder. Yeah.
They have to have a sense of humor
cause it's fucking freezing. Yeah.
So we get the best as far as cool guys
to hang out with. And I love my movie,
how to be a man, did incredibly well
with Hispanics. More than this. What is,
I don't know, I'm not even aware of this.
Oh, I did a movie called how to be a man.
What was it? It was a comedy about
a guy who's dying a fiction. Yes.
And he's recording videos
for his unborn son.
So after he dies the kid can watch the
videos and uh Huh. Learn from that,
which we stole from the
Michael Keaton movie,
which we mentioned in
the film at the time. Uh,
and I just assumed it would
do well with hipsters.
Then we've got the demo back and it was
like all Hispanics cause they're the
only ones into how to be a man.
Most millennials think it's a bad
thing to be a man. But anyway,
so I love Mexicans. Right? But we
just don't want, come on over here.
We have immigration work now
as a fucking disgusting man.
It's funny you say that because you're
an immigrant. Yeah. I took 10 years,
10,000 bucks, brought a heap load
of jobs and I got punished for it.
How'd you get punished?
I was charged 10 granted to be 10 years,
but that doesn't seem like punishment.
That seems like fucking citizenship.
I'm another 650 bucks away in a bullshit
test. About what color is the flag?
Why do you want to be an American citizen?
You don't want to be as citizens
of your names right now.
If I drunk drive or do something bad,
it could fuck up my green card and
okay.
Shit like that. Oh, so you
want to be able to drunk drive,
so that's why you want an American
citizenship. Uh, that's not why,
but I do thoroughly enjoy drunk
driving. I think it's a really, yeah.
Okay.
Do you drive drunk? No, it's the best.
It's like playing a video game. Oh,
come on man. You don't mean Blah blackout,
but seven beers. That's a fun time.
God Damn Dude, that's really
drunk. Like you're, you're,
you're fucking reaction times terrible.
Something happens.
You could slam right into things.
No. Drunk driving is a myth. Wow.
What do you mean it's a myth?
What does that mean? I mean,
the world wouldn't be better
if the world wouldn't change.
If it was made legal
people would not,
people don't jeopardize their own safety.
It's, you know, in America, in New York,
sorry. Uh, it's illegal
to drive after two beers.
You shouldn't be commanding a vehicle
if you can't handle it on two beers.
Two Beers right now. Yeah. It's, Oh,
what is it? Oh eight or o nine o nine.
Yeah.
Well that I think is low,
but I think that's also a revenue
collecting device. Totally. You know,
I think recycling,
I think if you could do a test of people's
coordination and after two beers you
would find it's really not much different
than being sober, but seven beers,
big fucking difference. Driving is simple.
Think of how we drive is not simple.
If something goes wrong and you have to
make a split second decision and your
reaction time is fucked up,
so a collision occurs that wouldn't
have occurred if you weren't drunk.
That's where it becomes a problem
and super anti drunk driving.
If the shit hits the fan,
if the shit hits the fan,
you can't keep it together as much fan,
if something happens in front of you,
a DRM on your brakes, a deer, a
person, someone makes a mistake,
someone goes into your lane, you could
cause a collision because you're drunk,
where you would avoid it if
you were sober. That's a fact.
People are jumping out on the highway
now on the scenario is cars making a
mistake? Someone coming into your realm
in your lane ball, you bonked. No,
you don't Bonk, you collide and
people die. It happens all the time.
Car Accidents on the highway or fucking
deadly people happen all the time.
You can accidentally, like Caitlyn Jenner
did push someone into fucking traffic.
They get his head on. Texting is way more.
He wasn't texting, he just spaced out.
She was texting. Why is he here?
He was he then, why did he say,
I think you already had fake tits. He
was a, or at least take a bull dyke.
Then he had a sweatshirt on and he
was like, they had that big face,
the big man face before he turned into
a texting. I can't remember. I saw,
I don't think he was,
I don't think that's ever been proven.
I think that was the part of the
investigation they found out and my main
platform when he ran for president.
But I think drunk driving is not an issue.
I thoroughly enjoy it. I mean I've, Roger
Avery killed somebody drunk driving.
Okay.
The guy who wrote pulp fiction with
Quentin Tarantino hundreds of right now.
But think of how many cars are
going opposite directions. Right?
And we only have what?
40,000 deaths a year.
But don't you think that people like
are less likely to drunk drive because
they're terrified of losing their
license? That terrified. Yeah,
so they do it less and less fun.
That's why La is less fun. Fun.
La is not fun because people don't drink.
I'm talking to you because I don't know
when you're fucking around and when
you're, when you're
being serious. La Sucks.
I fucking hate this
city with a passionate,
you're doing it when is
sort of under here. Silly.
Ours don't open at any given time and
everyone's petrified of drunk driving so
they don't even drink when they go
out. People go, no, they do drink.
They get Uber's. Uber's are
everywhere now. Recent. Yeah,
but that's what they do know.
Okay, well I can't wait to post,
but we're,
we're going back like three years now.
I'm talking about La really only
since I've been coming here,
which is Uber things like one and a
half maybe like we're really pumping.
Adopted it.
Maybe la is getting better since Uber.
Dla I know is fucking shittily
dressed squares. What about you?
You think that's a good time?
Yeah, I'll kill you at that tie.
That's probably the problem with that tie.
If you got you and I,
that's when I got here. Officer
altercation. Got An altercation,
I would kill you with their tie. Do you
know that? That it's not good for combat.
It's not a good combo. Terrible.
But as you have the leash,
the leash around your neck,
and I control you what that means,
sharing it into the cage match.
I could get my hands underneath
that day and I twist.
So you're think I'm criticizing
your town? No, I'm not.
Look here. You mess. Go to New York and
go. Holy Fuck. No, that's ridiculous.
Disneyland don't fun.
I don't think it's a good idea to have
that many people jammed into a place,
whether it's here or there.
I don't like it when I left.
We don't have that problem here. You
have their person, sidewalk, Empty Cup,
uh, fucking tumbleweed
person. Fucking abandoned.
Look at palm trees. They're not even
wood. That's not a tree. No, it's not.
It's plant hideous. Plan.
Why is it not a treat?
Why is it not a tree you can't
get wood from? It's right. It's
got dead leaves hanging off and you
go to like a carpet store and in West
Hollywood and you go, oh, this must be
abandoned. The paint is chipping off.
No one likes this place. No, it's
open. It's actually super expensive.
You can't even park your fucking car.
They have these so you don't need a
house of car. You take the subway.
I am an American and I enjoy autopay.
Then take your car.
You're only fucking 30
minutes from awesome forests
and fucking shooting bears.
You mean over there? Up there? Well,
I shot an elk an hour and a
half away from here. Okay,
well that's pretty much earth, earth
and the hour and a half away from elk.
This may,
I mean maybe not Europe,
but as far as you know
where you would want a hunt,
you're usually an hour and
a half away from nature.
Do you honestly think La Sucks?
No, I don't think La is ideal,
but I think la has a lot of great things.
I think the real problem
is overpopulation. I think
whenever you have too many,
you know all the time.
Notice, sorry, San Diego Man.
I worked in San Diego last night
and we drove down to San Diego.
We had to leave at 1230 and it took us,
it only took us three hours to get
there, which is pretty good. I mean,
it's really a two hour drive with
an hour of traffic. That's not bad.
But the last hour was all San
Diego traffic and I was like, wow,
this is crazy different than
it used to be a few years ago.
It's gotten a lot worse. San Diego fucking
reeks. I don't mean stinks literally,
but figuratively reeks way
worse in La and a lot of bumps.
I think skateboarding is illegal
there. That's a Shitty, it is.
What's a very conservative city.
Yeah.
San Diego is there and it's like they're
telling me that they suck black guy's
dicks on the weekends. I like, I go,
what? It's a conservative town. You know,
it's a lot of, a lot of military
people, a lot of bay, you know, it's,
the base is there. Here's the best cities
in the world. Who trekked? What's that?
It's near Amsterdam. Amsterdam
without the jocks. Oh, okay. Uh,
Barcelona. Barcelona is pretty
awesome. My friend Chris Ryan, just,
he's moving back there. Paris,
Paris, New York City, Montreal.
Um, so when you're in New York City, do
you take cabs? Do you to take the subway,
subway everywhere? Yeah. Now, full
disclosure, you say you don't know what,
I'm kidding,
but I'm serious.
I'm Kinda being pre 2015 gav
at 45 with three kids in New
York's been there 15 years,
to be totally honest is kills my argument,
but it is wearing on me a little bit.
I appreciate your honesty.
I don't think there's a reason to have
blind allegiance towards a particular
spot. I did for a long
time, but it was a lot.
Same to rats at once
regularly fucking saying no,
I'm done with the city to be honest.
Did you see the video of the
rat killing the pigeon? Oh,
Anthony had that on his show. Yeah. It
was an amazing unfucking. No, they hunted.
I didn't, I had no idea of rats
hunted. Rats hunted this pigeon jacked.
I mean it's like fit his neck.
Yeah.
And chased him like lost him for a bit
and then how to chase him and got him
again. Like it was crazy
everywhere. Fucking,
and you know what drives me nuts about
in New York, uh, sorry, pre 2015 Gav,
these fucking kids dancing on the subway
for money and they're swinging around
the Poles. You know what this, no,
they fucking so like you get on
the subway and the subway money,
I'm about to do a show, boom, boom boom.
And they get out and the shit
they're doing isn't depressive.
They're swinging around a
pole on the train and you go,
that's a stripper pole faggot.
You're a not as good as the strippers.
I usually see you're a loser and
then they'll do shit like though.
So they'll go upside down and slide down
as slowly and you can see the people
just moved here going,
oh my God.
And they go go to a strip club and
you'll see way better shit than that.
And then they do this thing with their
hat where they flip it and plop it on
their head. Like that's hard, right? Like
if, if we were drinking top path outside,
no baseball hat or the cracks in
their teeth and flip it on their head.
If we were drinking at an outside
bar and you did that, I would go, oh,
okay. Yeah, it would be. It is annoying.
It's fucking, and I didn't know that
that was going on. Yeah. It's a thing.
Most people don't know this. You're
educating a lot of folks, right?
They will kick you in the head
too really well by accident.
You know when they're spinning around,
all New Yorkers got those fucking guys
start near me and they fucking touch me.
They're all going down.
Wow. And it's like seven.
It's a 10 year old Yorker impression.
It's old school. Irish hell's kitchen guy.
Hell's kitchen. Yeah. That's the night
Simon. And those guys are fucking,
cause I said when they say
shit like that, I go, yeah.
But then you're in the New York post
in that little sliver that says,
man in subway stabbed to
death after altercation.
Well how much violence does go on in the
subways because you always hear about
the bad incidents,
but every day millions of people are
going back and forth and back and forth,
back and forth. It's not in New York,
a hunt, there's a murderer a day.
All East New York, all Bushwick, bloods,
crips, most of the gangs are Hispanic.
One a day, one a day on
average. That's not, that's more
maybe 400 a year. But yeah.
Well, West Hollywood only had
one murder this whole year.
Happened to the comedy store a couple
of nights ago. No Way. Yeah. Yeah.
Who Was it done? Bears. He
killed, killed on stage. No,
there was a, um, uh,
a guy who apparently wasn't even a comic
and he was out on the patio and someone
walked up to him and shot him six times
in front of everybody, you know, maybe,
uh, brutal debt. Uh, they
think it was gang related.
It's all speculation. Yeah. And it was a,
they had a black comedy night, you know,
urban in quotes,
urban comedy night,
and they'd had some issues with
gang members there before allegedly,
or we probably made fun of a dude. I don't
think so. He wasn't a comic. Oh yeah.
They think he just was a guy that
they knew he was going to be there.
Compton culture visiting. Yeah. West
Hollywood. And I was seeing what
they go through every day probably.
Yeah. Something along those lines.
But I found it amazing that that was
the only murder in Hollywood for a year,
wasn't it? All gays in Hollywood,
West Hollywood, that area. Um,
like below that is very gay.
Not all gays,
but a lot of straight people move to
those areas because they're super safe
because we're the gays live. It's like
they take care of everything. Well,
gays are happy because they
get laid a lot. Hmm. That
makes a big difference. See,
that kills your argument about gays
having a problem. It seems like,
I never said gates.
I have a problem.
It's good at like the tiny
contingent of bitchy gaze.
Most gays don't give a fuck now what?
We'd never figured out what,
what did Marian get upset with?
It was,
it was after the show said the problem
with education is systemic word.
I hate more than the word bat shit crazy.
You don't hate you.
I hate the word bat shit. What
the fuck does that mean? Well,
batch it is really dangerous.
Guano. Oh, I never knew that. Yeah.
This is a funny story. You're making
me hate the word less. There was,
he's a scientist and a,
there's a particular cave in Africa and
so they had set up to make this video of
these bats coming out of the cave cause
millions and millions of bats on a
nightly basis come out of this cave.
And so they set up, set up the cameras.
What they didn't anticipate is that these
bats, when they come out of the cave,
they release their bowels oh instantly.
So they were literally covered in bat
shit like swarms and millions and millions
of bats shitting all over them.
And they develop these hemorrhagic
viruses. He's horrible diseases,
bleeding from their eyes,
just horrific.
And they were dead within a week and
they don't know what the fuck killed them
and the they, you know, they had
to [inaudible] crazy anymore. Yeah.
Thank you for that shit is dangerous
again. Yeah, go ahead. Go ahead.
We're gonna wrap this up soon
anyway. As soon as you come back. No,
I don't do reads during the show.
It's fallen apart a little bit.
Fallen apart with his bladder.
He's a little off on the teacher
wages. Okay. Let's see what it is.
Of course he is closer to
15 to 20 bucks average.
This is a US average. Oh,
okay. Well there you go. Yeah.
Median hourly rate by job. Yeah, I
didn't believe that. That $60 an hour.
That seems kind of silly.
He's of,
it's really interesting
because he's a very smart guy,
but it's almost like he's purposely like
sabotaging real intellectual debate.
He like kind of what I said,
Fox News earlier.
It's just like they're making points to
make a point and then they went to argue
the point. Well he gets into it and
then he sabotaged it with humor.
Like you fucked it up and like,
it's almost like this is a strategic use
of the word faggot. Hey, look at the, uh,
the actual statistics for how much
teachers get paid. It's a lot less.
$11 for substitute teacher.
$14 for preschool. Uh,
elementary school.
$15
an hour. High School, $20.
Now imagine getting $20.
That's the highest rate they get by
the way. But imagine getting $20.
That's out of my ass.
I've looked this up. Well,
have a seat so we can hear you on the
microphone. Okay, good. Over here.
He doesn't just fine.
What is the source?
payscale.com and keep it
up there? Where's this? Uh,
where are they getting this from?
payscale.com willing of seven,
1200 people from all over the United
States. Totally different numbers.
Th th the teachers is the most
powerful union in the world.
They fund both sides on Capitol Hill,
so it's heresy. This is like black
helicopters and nine 11 was an inside job.
And then teachers, really big mentors.
They act like the mafia, like you will,
he will get your window smashed when you
fuck with the, uh, what do they call it?
The NDA. So you guys, anyway,
back to the Mark Marin thing.
You guys had a problem with the
worst word systemic and bat crazy.
That shit crazy. He said this
not just one thing. Right.
I agree with him and I had sense.
I go, yes there is just one thing.
And what is all one thing make it
possible to fire a fucking public school
teacher that would help.
That would certainly help.
Pretty shades in Harlem
with charter schools.
They can get fired and Harlem is doing
awesome with that. Just one little thing.
But what did he get upset about?
There was the transforming guessing that
that's why he didn't like to show Oh,
just that as far as verifiable,
uh, it was in the tank, the show.
And then when my transphobia controversy
exploded cause you wrote that article,
he's his people,
whatever said we're not airing this
show because judging by your views on
trends, people, the
interviews now incomplete.
Hmm.
So I guess it was like
saying we interviewed the
head of the KKK about fruits
and vegetables and then find out
later he's the head of the KKK.
This would look stupid to put out
talking about food the whole time.
Or say I shot the president
after you'd go, wait a minute,
we talked to the guy who
killed the president and we
didn't mention the shooting
the president.
So because of the fact that your
article came out after the interview,
he couldn't just release the interview
because it didn't discuss this very
important topic. That's his side. Yes.
That seems like it's not that important
a topic except to those people or if
you're talking about that subject,
I don't think that the subject
of transgender people is
like an integral part of
who you are or,
uh,
call me or have your people call
me and I'm in La all the time.
Or doing a dentists say update or say,
Hey, I didn't know you were this weird.
Youth. Don't think it's cool to cut
your cock off. Uh, let's discuss. Jeez,
but you did not think.
It's like,
do you think people should be able
to do whatever they want? Yes,
but we're getting back to
this gay marriage thing.
When you normalize the transgendered,
we end up in a situation where kids
are taking hormone blockers to prevent
puberty. We're clapping like
fucking losers. When a little boy,
a little gay boy gets female estrogen,
when? When should it be? Okay?
Like with Bailey, Jay,
you look at Billy j,
doesn't she look like that slightly
mentally it'll gay man. Uh, mentally ill,
gay man. Who am I like what
sky? What's mentally ill?
He doesn't think he's a man
that's a gender dysphoria
that is well documented as
a mental disorder. Well, one,
the thing I like about him is he can
cut his tits off when he realizes what's
going on and be normal. There's no old
Bailey Jay. You realize there's no, like,
I am barely Jay. I've been gardening
all day or my knight in shining all.
No, they don't. What do they do? They
ask themselves suicide. They fucking,
they go back become a meth head and they
get stabbed in a bad drug deal or a no.
Is that they remove their ted ours because
it's almost like what they want to be
a woman. You're not, you can't
be a woman. You can't be a bat.
You can't be a giraffe. Becoming a woman
is not something you get off a shelf.
What's the matter with homosexuals,
but they don't want to be homosexual
like a lot of them is a perfect example.
The one that we're talking about,
the MMA fighter, she's now a lesbian.
She still likes women.
Like she was a,
she was a man for 30 years and then
became a woman who still likes women.
She is a wildly mentally disturbed gay
weight. Straight, straight. Yeah.
Yeah. Fucking crazy straight dude.
He's this crazy man
and that's a great example. I'm glad you
brought that up because you're saying,
what's your problem? Why do you
hate all this shit? And I go,
obviously I don't fucking care.
Like if you're on a mountain and
you do something to yourself,
you can cut your face off. They're just,
there was just a woman in the news.
She decided she wanted to be blind and
she had a physician puts Shinar and
chemicals in her eyes.
She's blind fucking insane.
I don't want to make that illegal,
but I want to also say,
let's not normalize this because someone
who is kind of dumb and crazy and
thinks they want to invite, now
you've made it. Okay. So the,
the MMA fight is a perfect example of
the problem with this whole la live and
let live thing.
Cause now we have a dude with tits and
a fake cont kicking the shit out of
chicks. Well there was a really
funny time where this guy was, uh,
when Rachel Dolezal came
out as Trans Racial,
this guy was supporting trans
racial and uh, he was right. He was,
but he was joking.
He was trolling and there were so many
people that were arguing back and forth
on his Twitter feed. He's a comic, I
guess from England. And uh, you know,
he was calling it wrong skin
hashtag wrong skin. And, but it was,
it was a hilarious to watch
these semantics arguments.
Here's one that you'll find funny.
Okay.
I got in an argument with someone about
the MMA thing and a about the woman who
was a man for 30 years.
It became a woman and she said she
was always a woman and I said, really?
I said even when she was a man having
sex with another woman and making a baby
and she said even then, yeah,
I sound like that same durable,
I said that about Caitlyn Jenner.
So that means Kris Jenner was raped
because she thought she was having
sex with a man. Right. It's a seven.
It was a woman deception. That's a
crime. I assume it is in New Jersey.
Especially in the definition of rape today
where you, if you regretted it's rape.
Yes. And if you look at him funny after
it's over, like that was bullshit.
That's rape. Got It. Regretting sex was
raped. I would be doing 10 life sentences.
Well you know the whole thing that's going
on with drinking where the man always
gets accused of rape. If two people were
drinking together, if the woman is drunk,
if the woman is drunk and is
doing one of your favorite things,
drunk driving and she kills people,
she's responsible for her actions.
But if a woman is drunk
and she has sex with a man,
apparently she cannot consent.
That's another great example of what
we're talking about because in the MMA
situation you lied and said woman or man,
and I have a man being the show.
Well she didn't lie. She didn't disclose
the fact that she used to be a man.
That's how she looked at it. She
said it's a medical can. Exactly.
So you've got to check beaten up and
then with the drinking thing you go,
wait a minute.
So all drunk sex is rape.
Now we have like there was a woman who
was kicked off a flight for joining the
mile high club. Really? Yeah.
Cause she was belligerent and she was
fucking some dude in the bathroom and
screaming Ah, ah, oh, like
wasted my kind of girl.
And then she gets in a
fight with the staff,
the stewards or whatever
they're called these days.
The waitresses in the sky and uh,
uh,
she gets arrested cause she
was fist fighting them and
screaming and, and you go,
well wait a minute, you were
raped, you were drunk, drunk,
you were drunk having sex.
So you should be charging that guy.
And when you reinvent the system
and change all the definitions,
you have to take into account
the victims here. Like,
well they've got on a blue band and the
alcohol thing outside of colleges, they,
feminists were pushing
that for a few years ago.
They were trying to push at nationwide.
But then it became preposterous because
you realize everyone's a fucking rapist
because the whole country is filled with
rapists because socially people drink
and that's how they wind up fucking so
the people under the influence that we're
having sex, it's like 80%. It's
something, it's something nuts.
That's why we're here.
I mean I wouldn't be alive if
drunk sex was rape or illegal,
but when you do all this shit and you,
you reboot the system,
what you're actually doing
is trivializing reality.
And if you say drunk sex is rape,
some fucking woman who was raped at
knife point by a guy in a ski mask is now
your peer.
You've just trivialize that.
And when you say Rachel
Dolezal is black youth,
it's trivialized every black person's
experience who you grew up with,
real racism. And when you say
that Caitlyn Jenner is a woman,
you've trivialized womanhood now,
like this woman who gave birth and had,
you know,
she's a grandmother and there's a family
reunion and she's the matriarch that
basically built all these 60 people.
She's the same as this fucking guy
who put some fake tits. Bailey. Jay,
you've that's sexist.
You've trivialized it. Well,
it's certainly a weird thing.
I don't know if you've trivialized it
because I don't think it diminishes real
women in any way, shape or form does not
in my eyes. Okay, I'm a woman. We are,
we have been suffering, we
are oppressed. We get raped.
And then some dude in a way it
goes, yeah, it's a fucking insane.
We are getting harassed on the street.
And she's looking at him going, oh,
well I was actually really
raped. So was I. I had drunk sex.
Well, you just shat on her whole
experience with your bullshit wig.
I don't know if you do, but I see what
you're saying. I see what you're saying.
I just think black face and go in
the million man march and go, Yo,
this shit is outrageous man.
But what about the guy who's a,
one of the guys from black lives
matter on Shaun King, who's wife like,
I feel like I'm the same liberal kid I
was when I was a punk teenager, right?
I don't like Rachel Dolezal in
Shaun King because they are racist,
racist,
but they identify with black people.
They are trivializing
the black experience.
I don't like Islam because they're sexist.
I don't like fucking feminists because
they deprive women of the joy of having
babies and they trivialize
what it is to be a real woman.
Their whole sort of anti southern
Belle thing is anti woman.
I'm still a feminist,
anti racist fucking punk rocker.
You're a feminist.
I'm a feminist in the sense that I, I,
as Donald Trump says, I adore women.
I like women. I think that's the
definition of a feminist, right?
A feminist is someone who had,
that definitely has merit to
femininity to women. Yeah.
That's how they use it though. I know that
today it means, oh, you're a feminist.
If you think men or women,
you think women are bad ass and
kick ass during kickass too,
and they're doing circle kicks.
You know what my favorite is when
they say that if you are a feminist,
there's no need for any
other sort of equality,
gender equality issue because
feminism addresses all of it.
So there's no need to have men's
rights issues because once feminism is
completely achieved, once female
rights are equal to men's rights,
then they will address all
the other rights. I actually,
I talked to a feminist
about that and I said, okay,
so you must hate the amount of prison
rape going on, Eh, with men, right?
And she goes, yes, we do. And I go,
I can't even conceive of feminists
standing outside of prison with placards
going stuck the raping of these guys.
Well, the promise of being raped by guys,
like when they say that more than men
or be the line when they say their
humanists, they don't care
if it's made. Right. Well,
I think a lot of when you,
when you're looking at these really
unattractive women that happened just so
happened to be feminist.
Again,
we're not saying that all feminists
are unattractive, but I've,
I have friends and I'm sure you do too,
that are just ugly dude's and they
grow to hate women because they're just
associate women with rejection and
feeling bad and they're just getting just
constantly shit on by women like fuck
these bitches and they develop that sort
of mentality.
It's just seems to be like a natural
course of progression that some really
unattractive women would be like really
hostile to men too because all their
life they've been rejected and made
to feel terrible by men. Right?
Yeah, I agree, but I don't understand
why they don't try like try what?
Grow your hair long,
wear high heel shoes.
Maybe they be around the last call and
I'll fuck you. But here's the thing,
a really hot chick with purple hair
and it's short and she's got a fucking
banging body.
Oh fuck the shit out of it.
You wouldn't even care that he wouldn't
even care. He'd be like, you sexy bitch.
Like we don't like short hair. We
don't like Birkenstocks. I don't know.
I used to date this girl. She had
a shaved head. She was hot as fuck.
When you fuck them from behind, it looks
like a dude does. I don't like that.
That's great. Very small dude with
a big ass fat 12 year old boy.
It. We have a women talk
about unattainable, uh, uh,
expectations for men.
That's gays and women coming and put
those expectations were pretty cool.
Like grow your hair long,
wear high heel shoes,
even if you're fat w put on some
lingerie and we'll work it out.
Do you think that there's,
what's going on with a lot of this is
that there's a lot of people that are,
they have these standards that they
feel like they've, they're supposed to,
they're supposed to uphold or
they're supposed to live up to,
but now they have a voice.
They have a voice because of the Internet,
because they find likeminded people
online and they get really active in those
communities and it gives them a sense
of community and a sense of, uh, of,
of purpose that they never
had before. Totally. Yeah.
They don't really believe it.
I saw some feminist girl, you know,
they hold their stupid fucking signs.
I love those signs and the sign said,
I'm sorry,
my breasts aren't big enough and she
had like pretty decent tits and I'm
thinking, I'll fucking come on
your tits. Like, I don't care.
That is feminism right there.
You're a feminist.
I've met maybe one guy in my life who
likes fake tits. I, I dated a girl,
had fake tits and she sat me down and
we had a talk where she told me I had to
pay more attention to her breasts because
I would be like face, neck, shoulders.
She sat down and had a talk. Yeah.
Cause she's like, what did she say?
You need to pay more attention to my
breasts. Wow. My Dad could have those.
I can't get into it. I
can feel the scene. Yeah.
Well the old ones especially,
they're really good now.
They have some new ones now that are like,
they're,
they're a solid instead of a bag of
water now it's like a silicon mushy thing
where it feels exactly like breast tissue
allegedly. I like your shitty tits.
You like regular natural tits. I like,
it's like my buddy Trevor said he goes,
when I was 20 I dated a girl
with droopy tits and I hated it,
but I was sure wouldn't mind
fucking with them right now.
Like a girl doggy style and
they're hanging down like
fucking bags and swinging.
I like that. I couldn't look at them
or I'd come. Wow. Yeah. Really? Yeah.
When you get older,
your,
your spectrum of attractiveness
increases and you're like, Ooh,
I'm fucking from Ohana can sort
of smell poop. I love it. Oh,
just a faint whiff. Yeah.
Don't get like a woman's ass.
And you're feeling like a woman
who'd washes that ass first gross.
I know too much about
bacteria. Oh, that's it.
Like a Jew [inaudible] la all this time.
Yeah.
You've taken on their
paranoia about gender
Fred staph infection
that almost killed him.
I want queefs I don't break for queefs.
You know,
like you're fucking going and you hear
that and they sort of want to stop. Yeah.
Fucking right. That's like I'm driving on
the highway and someone goes, hey, okay.
Let me ask you this. You, he pussy when
they're on their period. Uh, I used to,
but as I got older, no.
Hmm. I don't give a fuck.
I used to fuck chicks with Shane
a lot. And uh, how dare you,
we would accidentally
touch Dick's sometimes.
Like one time I was
like the operation game.
I thought it was fucking a girl in
her ass and it went into her cunt and
actually went into his condom inside.
I'm looking down at her how looses his
cotton? What is it? A fucking trash bag.
I was harder than makes sense.
At least resistance.
So I'm looking down at me like I swear
to God I got inside his condom. Yup.
So using the condom ever believes me
container so that you guys could rub dicks
together. But that wasn't the
plan. But I was, I was like,
I'm fucking this bitch his ass.
And I looked down and I see
an asshole and I'm like,
how many assholes is this woman
that I'm in? At least one of them.
And then I reached down and I feel
a condom. How drunk were you guys?
Not Drunk at all? Well, how did you not
know where you're putting your Dick?
Don't you look? What are you looking
at you, you're, you're on the ass.
You're pushing and pushing and pushing
and then you sort of feel that it slipped.
So you go, oh, that must
have gone in a hole.
The one that was pushing a girl
doing the whole time, calling
like Donald Sutherland and invasion
of the body snatchers. Well,
she's got to Dixon and vagina.
She's fucking, oh Huster listen,
she was from Malta. I hate to wrap
this up on a, on a high note like that,
but we're out of time. Did
you already hear the end of
the story? Oh sure, please.
So anyway, I reached down, I
go, I didn't have a condom on,
I have a condom on and then I pull out
and I busted not on her butt and if
people go, but you touched a dick. But
when you're doing that kind of stuff,
it's like two mobsters digging a hole
for a body and their shovels clink.
Like you don't fucking care. You're
at work. Right. I understand. I still,
I wanted to go. How do you wrap
that up nice and tight. Um,
how can people see your show on
the Anthony [inaudible] Dot com?
Uh,
if you're especially a
thorough anthony.com/gavin,
is it available in audio
form as well? Yes, it is.
And they also do a best of
every week. That's free. Um,
and that has legion of skanks and
Anthony come in and my show, um,
and I do a column at Tacky Magaluf.
Dot. Jay [inaudible]. Hilarious.
One time he was talking shit about
me saying Gavin's has a lot of shit,
but I shot them down once
and I knew they were nearby.
So I got my car and he said he shot you
down. Yeah. Like in what way? Like Neil,
one of my arguments, he pointed a
hawk. So you've drove over there?
I drove over there. I knew it
was live and I was like, what?
I hear that all the time. What was
the thing? Right? And I'm sorry,
I can't remember the exact thing
you said. Dut, Dah, Dah, Dah.
And then later you said Dah,
Dah, Dah, Dah. And that shuts
you down. And I was like,
that is actually exactly what happened.
I still go back in the car and went home.
Like nailed. It happens. All right.
Thank you Kevin. Thanks for
having me. This was fun. Thank
you very much. Thank you.
All Right Gavin. Mcinnes
ladies and gentlemen, we'll be
back. See you soon. Bye. Bye.
Big Kiss.
That was the funnest car.